failure is a really interesting topic
and it's something that we see as a bad
thing for some reason where failure is
really feedback failure is a learning
experience failure is only really fail
if you don't take anything and learn
from it and anytime you're trying to
learn something you will fail at the
start you will suck at the start right
you want to learn French you're going to
fail along the way to learning French
right you want to get up on a snowboard
you're not going to ace it the first
time down you're going to fall fall fall
fall fall and eventually you make it up
right and people try something out for
the first time when they're not
successful at it and a lot of them will
then say yeah I'm not an oh that's not
for me I can't do this and they go back
to their life that they hate uh
showcasing a failure is not this really
negative thing that we want to run away
from because if you have no failures it
means you're playing life so safe that
you've never taken any any risk at
anything any shot at anything right you
you have a dream to accomplish something
you're going to fail a lot to get there
and I just see failur as feedback not as
something that is a negative
thing there's a lot of talk in the
Creator Community now about burnout you
know people one year in on their career
and they're burning out like well I've
been doing this for 14 years and haven't
burnt out yet because I I still love the
process of doing the thing so what is
work is this work like is a is a
interview with Shan work like like it's
not for me if I when it's in my calendar
it's like oh cool I get to talk to Sean
today this would be a fun conversation
the second it becomes like oh man I
don't want to go on this podcast then
what am I doing then then I should I
should stop and move on to something
else and same thing with making videos
making videos I like the process of
doing it the the profiles that we do I
need for me I listen to every morning I
I need them in my life and so even if
nobody liked them I would still have a
skeleton team doing it for me just so
that I had something every morning to
watch and I think what ends up happening
is a lot of entrepreneurs they get
caught up on running their business and
just trying to play to the algorithm or
just trying to play to the market and
they end up falling out of love with the
thing that they're doing in the first
place which then leads to burnout which
then leads to unhappiness which then
leads to side projects and side hustles
and all these other things where it's
like well no just keep doing like make
sure you're checking in and that you're
loving the work you love the process for
me it's not about
hitting how whatever the next sub four
million subscribers or five million
subscrib whatever the next goal is it's
like I like waking up every day and
doing what I'm doing the biggest thing
that I struggled with at the beginning
was belief
and and still now but I'm I'm a lot more
confident have more self-belief now than
I did 5 years ago or 10 years ago or
whatever um when I started my
channel there was a YouTube worth of
million subscribers like it wasn't even
a thing I was just making videos just
because I wanted to serve like if 50
people saw the video like wow 50 people
saw this great let's go right but it's
still the thing that I need most for the
next level and I find that that's that's
CA right like if your main thing is
pivoting your biggest strength is that
you pivoted your biggest strength is
that you helped other people pivot and
the biggest thing holding you back is
like the next
pivot what's the next pivot I start with
purpose and I I think your purpose comes
from your pain so whatever you struggled
the most with is what you want to help
other people through so I struggled so
much as an entrepreneur and getting my
first business off the ground and
quitting and having $300 a month and all
this stuff and so I just want to try to
make the road a little bit easier for
other entrepreneurs to not have to
struggle as much as I did and there's so
many great causes in the world but
what's the one that you're going to want
to commit to well it's the one that you
feel most connected to if you don't care
about entrepreneurs then cool don't
worry about entrepreneurs focus on the
thing that you care about the most so
that's you know I think everybody needs
to starts with purpose because if you
woke up and felt like you're going to do
something today that matters because
it's serving somebody else you're much
more likely to stay consistent you know
I've done what what year is it 2023 I've
uh started in 2009 so it's been a lot of
making videos over the years why why do
I stay consistent because I still feel
connected to the purpose of what I'm
doing also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there what advice do you have for
aspiring YouTubers that are starting
from ground
one uh expect a suck at the
beginning expect a suck like you might
look at Allan and say wow Allan looks so
great and he gets all these guests on
and he looks so professional and he asks
these great questions and he looks so
comfortable in front of the camera and
like I wish I could be Allen right but
but Allan wasn't Allen either at the
beginning you know Allan sucked at the
start go watch episode one I don't know
I haven't seen episode one but it's
probably not as clean and Polished and
there's mistakes and flubs and like
episode one is supposed to suck so just
expect to suck at the start don't don't
take that as you suck as a human like
that's the problem is we make something
it sucks we watch ourselves back on
camera it's like oh my gosh I was so bad
I can't believe it was that bad and then
we internalize that to feel like well
well we suck and I'm just not good at
this and it's not meant for me and I'll
never do it no like you get on a bike
and you fall off this this is the nature
of learning any skill it's just a skill
so expect the suck at the beginning and
then create go make like make another
video and another video and another
video it took me 350 videos until I
wasn't completely embarrassed by my
stuff like I couldn't watch it back I
would I would press play oh it's so bad
350 videos and 700 videos until I
inspired myself where I watched the
video like you know what like I'm I
might be getting good at this thing huh
700 videos in and I think most people
can get there a lot faster than it took
me to get down that path um and we just
have these unrealistic internal
expectations for how good we should be
so so expect the suck and then just go
create and keep making content I think
one of the biggest mistakes I made early
on when I when I had any money was I
just tried to invest it and put into the
stock market and I remember like I had
2,000 bucks like okay I'm going to put
it in the stock market it's going to
grow it's like oh it's like taking so
long to grow it's only 2,000 where
Jeremy actually made a much smarter call
like I think at the beginning you invest
in your skills and you invest in your
network because that $2,500 investment
that Jeremy made now has a mid six
figure or high six figure business every
year because it came to that event but
if you just put it into the stock market
sure it would grow but I think at the
beginning you need to invest in yourself
to get the skills that you need to be
able to then create the network and
create value for other people yeah and
and when entrepreneurs any entrepreneur
here watching you're thinking about
starting your business the easiest way
to start making money is to provide a
high value business or service to people
who have money to pay you and so getting
into YouTube Consulting is great because
there's not a ton of people into it yeah
right it hasn't been around for 40 years
if you're going to get into tax
accounting that's a great business to be
into but you have to have years of
experience to know what you're doing
right I did um I did an interview with
Tom on his channel like that guy's an
expert he's a genius he's a genius so if
you're G to go and compete with Tom it's
going to take you so many years to even
catch up to a base level of knowledge
but in YouTube Consulting it's easier
because there is nobody really who's
been doing this for 40 years right or
you're a chat GPT consultant and you're
helping use AI for people in the co who
is the expert on that like there's
nobody because it's still so brand new
so this is the area where it's super
high value for clients but there aren't
a lot of experts at it so for you to
spend six months becoming great at it
you could be now in the top 1% of all
people who know how to use that thing
and then start charging for your
services on top of it there are things
that are triggers for me now like three
words scary difficult hard if I say
those think those write those I have to
go do that
thing because I want to all together or
one at a time any of them like if I said
if you said hey Evan you should you
should go do X and I said oh that that's
really hard okay now I gotta do it
because I don't want to accept hard as a
reason to not do right um hence hence
the Dorito bags yeah like the Dorito the
Dorito is a
crazy that there are some things with me
that are easy to connect with like
introverted shy humble Canadian whatever
um and there are others that are more
difficult to connect with so the Doritos
bag is one of the more challenging
things to to connect with because that's
more of a hard push where when you're on
a diet the usual strategies is get rid
of the food get rid of junk food from
your house that's what people always say
and and I think that's a good first step
but it's you're basically walking on
crutches so when you break your leg you
use crutches yes awesome but your goal
is to be able to to walk and to run and
to live a normal life so if you can only
win when you're in your perfect
environment well what happens when you
go on a cruise or office party or
vacation you're just pounding back the
food if I'm scared to come and do this
show right and like oh my gosh paty and
I hope she cancels on me when I going to
answer I nervous right and and I and my
feel my heart bit so scary difficult
heart is one the other is I have a boom
boom boom test which is if my heart is
beaten out of my chest that's a physical
manifestation of scary difficult heart
which means I have to go do that thing
too so if I'm if I'm I used to want
people to cancel on me like if I saw you
I'd say yes in two months we'll do this
thing but then I'd see like oh my God
Patty and today I hope she cancels I
don't want to disappoint her this is
gonna be terrible boom boom boom bo boom
boom boom physical sign I have to go off
and do it even if I showed up and and
vomited all over my microphone and the
camera because I was so nervous I would
still mentally reward myself to say you
did the hard thing you have to do the
work that you don't see as work uh Jerry
Seinfeld calls it the torture that you
can endure it's like for a lot of people
what you're doing staying up to three:
in the morning just to do a YouTube
Interview people are like dude that's
crazy that's torture I would never do
that right for people jumping into my
schedule like to make three YouTube
videos every day they would think that
that's tortur for me it's fun I enjoy
the process if you only have a goal and
you don't like the process you'll never
hit that goal yeah you have to enjoy the
actual work like if you're gonna
interview people you have to enjoy
interviewing people if you don't you're
never gonna have a good interview
Channel like other guys who love that
will crush you and so if you're just
starting out I think people easily get
tricked into looking at what are the
hottest Industries for this year and
what's the next big opportunity let's go
all in on bitcoin mean you know nothing
about Bitcoin yeah you know and then
that's that's a fastest way to lose your
money so you have to do the thing that
you love if you look at my YouTube
career uh I wasn't super talented uh I'm
not funny you know there's not a lot of
entertainment on the videos um they're
not coming for my dashing good looks uh
you know like it none of the only thing
I did was I just kept going I just kept
musling through like whatever the stats
you threw out at the beginning six years
I had 9,000 subscribers like most people
quit like you it's six years dude you've
been doing this for six years how are
you six years in and you still have
9,000 subscribers man like why are you
still doing this I just kept going right
that's the you know I just had it in me
to keep so that's maybe a stubbornness
or whatever I just loved it um but most
people don't uh don't don't have that
stubbornness I guess to just keep going
so that's why you know try to find
earlier wins but consistency for
anything like you are what you
consistently do if you eat one chocolate
bar you're fine if you eat a chocolate
bar every meal you're going to be kind
of screwed over um so whatever you want
to do you are what you consistently do
so um when you can tie yourself Worth to
the effort you're putting in on
releasing whatever the thing is like if
you're you want to be great at
podcasting great like well how great do
you want to be because you could do a
podcast a month and get okay you could
do a podcast a week can get a lot better
you can do a podcast a day and in a year
you'll be kickass like if you did a
podcast every day for the next year you
did 365 podcast if you did a podcast a
month how many how how many years does
it take to catch up to 365 it's like
it's never going to happen right right
um so and that's not to beat you up on
on that it's just whatever goals you
have when you take consistent action
you're going to win what are some steps
that you think people should take or can
take uh to get that momentum to add more
of that to their life I think it starts
with
identifying where do you lack right like
what do you want to get better at so for
you it's like hey I want to be a better
entrepreneur I don't have business
people in my life so I'm going to make
an effort to be around people who are
more successful at that thing so if you
have a health goal or relationship goal
business goal they don't it's not that
you have to hang your own Elon Musk to
get it right I mean there's lots of
people who've done it if if it's a
relationship goal who are the happiest
couples that you know and try to spend
more time with with them or health goal
who are the people who are running you
know or or just working out on their own
and how do you spend more time with them
when you're in that Circle you'll just
do a lot more so what is the thing that
you are lacking um and then I would
split that
between uh moments like an event or
conference or hanging out with somebody
and then what can you do consistently on
The Daily right so what ends up happen
is you get really motivated you go to a
conference you meet some people you
learn and it takes you to another level
but then it's easy to fall back down to
you know where you were like Oh I
thought I could I thought I could write
a book like I can't write a book I'm not
going to start a show I can't what where
did I think I could do that from because
you've been taken out of the environment
put back into your current environment
so it's harder to to get going again not
impossible but just harder but I love
those moments because it shows what's
possible and I'm a big believer that the
ideas that come to you when you're
feeling bold powerful confident
courageous are actually the right ones
for you like those are your best ideas
and then your head talks you down from
doing them because it doesn't it only
understands a world that currently
exists like well you didn't go to school
for this what you're going to be an
entrepreneur you can't be an
entrepreneur right like the head starts
to take over so those ideas that came to
you when you're at that conference
you're around these people like those
are actually the right ones for you and
you need to then inject new things daily
to remind yourself of the person you
want to be so that's why I have things
like my YouTube channel right cuz I need
a daily because I want to be around uh I
want to be around Oprah Winfrey and
Steve
and Elon Musk and Bill Gates and these
people every day that when I'm watching
their video it makes me want to go and
do more we all want to wake up and feel
like what we do matters if you woke up
and you felt every day that you don't
matter to somebody else but the work you
do is meaningless it doesn't matter
that's the path down to anxiety stress
depression suicid where a lot of people
a lot of people wake up and feel like
just today's doesn't matter nobody cares
if I show up or
not but on the other hand if you felt
like today's going to matter today it
it'll mean something I'm going to make
something I'm going to show up for
somebody it's going to touch maybe not a
million lives but like one person's life
if you're going to show up and you're
going to take your mom to brunch and
it's going to touch her life it's like
I'm excited to show for today right and
so we all want to feel like the work
that we do
matters the people will love helping the
most are the people who currently are
who we used to be so when I said your
purpose comes from your pain whatever
you struggled through that made you feel
like The Biggest Loser of all time is
now what you want to help other people
through because there's lots of people
right now who feel like that loser and
they'll learn from you in a way that
they won't learn from me or Eddie or
Oprah or somebody else because you have
a different story and so we all you know
helping and serving is hardwired into
our brains you know it's the same they
did functional MRIs on people's brains
and found the same part of the brain
lights up when you're serving or helping
as when you're having food and having
sex so it's like like it we We crave the
desire to want to help people but
there's a difference between just
helping somebody cross the street or
holding the door for somebody or buying
the coffee like these little acts of
kindness
versus when you see somebody who's like
you and you help them overcome something
that then years later like when Eddie
says five years ago I don't know when I
talked to you haven't picked up the
phone and called me and how much of a
difference it made right that's that's
the stuff that makes me feel I don't
even remember I don't remember talking
to
any show you the email you'll get AI
out you I mean I remember you outside
the bathroom
so but like that those are the kind of
things that feel really good it makes me
want to keep doing it right that Eddie
said hey you took a chance on me and
gave me half an hour of your time or
however long we talked when I was just
getting started I mean I do that for a
ton of people who also don't go anywhere
right is it so it's not like it's great
to have a success story but not
everybody turns out to be and Eddie as
well uh but that becomes proof that I
should keep doing it makes me feel good
right you stopping me outside the
bathroom leading to this you know we
have a good conversation it makes me
want to say yes to the next guy if it's
a total you know like a disaster and we
the building's locked and his
microphone's not set up and he's like oh
maybe I don't say yes to the next guy I
don't know
right so but we all want to feel like
the work we do matters is an important
to people and every time we feel that it
does so much more for our Soul than just
holding the door for somebody or doing a
random act of kindness as a Creator we
often tend to kind of compare ourselves
to other others and and lose the focus
of the people who are already here who
are already following us and and
enjoying the stuff we have showing love
and we try to kind of focus on the stuff
we don't have so so that would really
resonated this is one of the things that
held me back the most because my biggest
fear is disappointing people
my biggest fear is that I'm going to I'm
going to get on stage or I'm going to
come to an interview and I'm going to
let you down and I'm not going to have
an answer and I'm not going to know what
to say and I don't want to waste your
time I don't want to waste the
audience's time and that used to hold me
back a lot from keeping the momentum
going I might start one thing and then
like there's an opportunity and and then
say no or cancel or or back out or like
hope they would cancel on me because my
I would be afraid that I would
disappoint people so the thing that
always saved me that I still use today
is focus on who you are serving you know
like focus on who you are serving
instead of who you aren't we in in the
comparison game of starting a YouTube
channel or starting an Instagram account
or getting on Tik Tok it's always easy
to look at well but look at look at
whoever you know look at the number one
look at what Joe Rogan's doing or look
at what Evan carmichel is doing or look
at what whoever else is doing and and
the game of who you're not never ends
there's always somebody who's better
than you at something right like the
only thing that you're best in the world
that is being Teemo right the only thing
I'm best for is being EV karmar on
there's always people who are better
than me at all these other skill sets
that I want to learn and get better at
and that's great because we never want
to stop learning you never want to have
it all figured out we want to be able to
climb forever but if you're only living
in the world of I'm not enough and like
who you're comparing yourself to I think
people that's what will often lead to
burnout that's what lead the people
quitting that's what lead to people
killing their momentum as opposed to
saying I am helping people right like
focus on who you are serving instead of
who you're not so in my first videos my
first video on
YouTube had three comments on it in a
year and one was my mom and one was my
sister and then one was some random guy
you know I was like so in a year of my
first video going up when people are
like I didn't get any comment man my
first video for a year only had one
comment by some random guy who I didn't
know and I saw that and like hey
somebody commented on my video this is
great and so if you can focus on people
you know they post something Instagram
and they have 40 views on their video
and they say I'm such a failure only 40
people saw this video well imagine if
you were going to go speak at a library
or or a school event or something like
40 people showed up wouldn't you be
excited wouldn't you be nervous wouldn't
you be like oh my God there's 40 people
here coming to see me but because it's
it's online we feel like we're just a
failure cuz somebody else posted one and
they got 40,000 and you're sitting here
with 40 and so I always just focused on
who I was serving those 40 people like
40 people watch this video and for maybe
for one of those people that this was a
life-changing video that for one person
the thing that I said was the piece of
advice that they needed to move the
needle forward in their life and that
always gave me
more fulfillment more happiness more
positivity knowing that I am helping
some people and and that I can continue
to help more and when you start doing
the work to help and focus on those 40
they take you to the 40,000 like if you
do a great job nurturing your community
then they take you to their friends and
their friends and their friends and
that's how you build up and grow so yeah
I think um the comparison game can often
uh hold us back there's some Advanced
strategies around that that can work but
when you focus on who you are serving
instead of who you're not I think it
leads to a lot more happiness which
leads to a lot more momentum as well if
you could give
anyone who is struggling not making
money in their business and they're
doing what they love and they're putting
the hard work and effort in what would
your one piece of advice
be um so on the business side I would
say you have to learn how to figure out
how to bring value to people so doing
what you love is not enough but chasing
strategy alone isn't enough either so a
successful business comes from mixing
what you love doing with what brings
value to other people if you just love
something but it doesn't bring value you
have a hobby and that could be a great
Hobby and fulfilling but it's not going
to become a business and if you're just
chasing opportunity what's the hot
business for this year you're never
going to ultimately win longterm because
your heart's not connected to it so and
you're going up against people who love
the thing and so it's in that
combination of the thing you love doing
that brings value to the people that you
have a successful business but I know
you only ask for one but i' I'd layer on
top of it just believe in what you're
doing like come back to the intent is is
my intent to serve is my intent to help
my even just helping three people I know
as entrepreneurs we want more more more
more more it's like we want to serve the
world we got to change Global
Consciousness right I mean this is where
we want to go but but did you help one
person this week you know that did one
person benefit and so imagine if you
stopped you know if you stopped then
those people won't get the message and
if you look back if you if you I try to
position sometimes to regret I imagine
myself being 120 looking back at this
moment it's like if I quit now will I
regret it and if so then just keep going
and if you can continue to focus on who
you are serving it's more the the mental
approach because when you feel like
you're doing something that matters and
you feel like you matter you just show
up with a lot more love and energy and
care than otherwise and so if your
intent is to serve and to help just keep
going because the world needs people
like you you'll never win doing work
that you hate like you'll never crush it
on your podcast if you show up every day
and you don't like the podcast or you
don't like the guest you don't like what
you're doing which means you have to
Pivot it may mean you I don't know the
back story behind stopping we do hard
things and moving to to the what's the
new sales one called what's this one how
to sell more how to sell more right
great there's a story right I mean at
some point you stopped liking doing that
it wasn't working or or they ran out of
time whatever but it wasn't okay that's
it I'm done all podcasting I'm never
talking anybody again I'm just going to
go and do something else like no I'm
going to launch a new show and so
everything has a time in place but yeah
if I look at my calendar and I and I'm
consistently not liking when something
shows up then you have to move on
because you're not going to win doing
work that you hate it's so easy to
complain and and it's a default mode
it's nice to think that it's the
president's fault that you're not
successful or your mom's fault or the
school system's fault or you don't have
enough money or whatever it's nice to
think that that's the reason and what
that does is by blaming somebody else it
puts you in an unresourceful state it
means it's not your fault so you don't
have to fix it it's your mom's fault mhm
it's the president's fault right it's
their fault so I'm going to complain and
be angry about it but I don't have to do
anything about it because it's not my
fault so it's when you say okay this is
actually my responsibility it may not be
your fault but it's your responsibility
to fix it that I can get I can get out
of this what that does is at the start
is well that sucks you know it's because
it's so nice to be able to blame
somebody now this sucks that it's on me
to go off and fix it but then it's also
the ultimate power in that you can
change your circumstances you can change
your situation you can make it better
just by saying it's on me to fix it like
there's no Cavalry coming by by kicking
the president out of office it doesn't
change your situation you know so so
stop waiting for something else to
happen like you are in charge uh and so
for for any spot in life like you were
you are where you are because of you and
I have a test that I call the mirror
test where you walk in the mirror go in
the bathroom or wherever you have a
mirror and ask yourself why am I not
more
successful why have I not hit my goals
and whatever the first thing that comes
back
when you look in the mirror those are
the excuses that you need to bust
through right because something's going
to come up that's an excuse It's a story
you're holding on to I don't have the
right parents or I don't go to the right
school or I don't know how to be
charismatic or whatever it's some it's
always some excuse um and that's the one
that you need to work on immediately to
fix so you can go build that better life
for yourself the first person I hired
was not in this YouTube business but but
way back in my first company and it was
for 1 hour a day
and I hired him to do one hour of work a
day because it freed up about an hour
and a half of my time per day and I
think honestly as soon as you can you
want to get somebody to help out it does
a couple things one it it it really
helps to not be doing this alone like it
really sucks to do everything all by
yourself just the emotional I mean you
guys have each other which is
great like join a group join Community
don't be alone because it's really
really really hard to be an entrepreneur
and do it all on your own when all of
those insecurities and fears and doubts
and like I'm not good enough and I was
so dumb for starting this and what was I
thinking and right uh so it's it's nice
to have somebody who's doing this with
you as opposed to you doing it all by
yourself plus it's just smart in that
you don't have to do all the work that
you can delicate some of the tasks away
to focus on whatever is you know more
inside of your passion and what you love
and what you can you know charge more
for as well to build your company so I
think a lot of people try to forget
about the past pain I think especially
entrepreneurs we're so you know
optimistic we want to make the world
better we're trying to live in a
positive Place uh that I had actually a
hard time remembering some of the super
painful moments and I don't like going
there but instead of trying to forget
and move past it if you can go live
there again just as a reminder of what
it like so that you can then help other
people living there and dwelling on
mistakes and and the hurt doesn't help
anything but if it allows you to connect
with the people who are currently going
through that situation and I think that
becomes your path like for the reason
why I came up with purpose from your
pain is it's one of the most common
questions I get is what's my purpose how
do I find my people are walking around
with no purpose they don't know what it
is and I think everybody has Michael
Jordan level Talent at something I think
you can be a genius at something and I
know that like Unleash Your greatness
this is what you're all about it's great
uh but people don't know how to find it
and I think it starts with that it
starts with understanding some of the
pain and Trauma that you've been through
whatever that was for you and then then
create something amazing you know every
great organization every great
entrepreneur who started out of a pain
that they had and then they wanted to go
off and solve it and so diving back into
your past to think about what were some
really painful moments and then how can
you turn that as a kick forward not a
kick down not that you know you suck but
you're going to now help others and and
make it better um and sharing the story
I think it's how entrepreneurs win I
think I think too often we're afraid to
share a lot of people be afraid to share
your story like you're coming out of
Tony Robins organization you're on top
of the world you're improving people's
lives and and you're sitting you know in
your parents' basement and it's five
years like that that story is what makes
people human it's what connects people
to each other and I think so many people
who are trying to start a business uh
try to be so corporate and so
professional and it's not that you can't
be professional but the thing that's
going to make somebody want to work with
you and connect with you in your mission
is your story I need to know why this is
so important to you why is this pain so
important and if you're telling some you
know fluffy story it's not going to work
but if it's true and real to you then
that's what's really going to draw
people in I love learning different
things from different people I'm in my
home office and you can see pictures for
those listeners I guess there's pictures
behind me on the my parents are in the
middle that's in the middle is me when
I'm like eight or nine of my above me
believe my one word my most important
core value comes from them um they
taught me how to be a human they didn't
teach me about business that's right so
okay great I've got Steve Jobs on the
wall here next to me he I like learning
how to be a Visionary like Steve Jobs
yes but I don't want to be a father like
Steve jobs was that's right I want to be
a father like my father was that's right
and so I love learning different things
from different people I think anybody
who's had success you can learn from
them and I honestly think some of your
greatest learnings will come from people
who you don't like have success they can
teach you when you can learn to learn
from someone who you don't like is when
I think you actually start learning wow
and so my favorite comment of all time
on my channel I profiled a uh a black
entrepreneur and I had a guy leave a
comment and say hey growing up my
parents told me that black people were
the nword yeah and today I just learned
from a black man yeah absolutely right
took five minutes to to watch a video
and and be open like hey put your put
your prejudices aside for five minutes
that's right and just see if there's
something here that you might learn was
the serving with the purpose to serve
was also a kind of like something
serving yourself to was that were you
attached to that
serving yeah I mean the ultimate form of
happiness is serving yeah I know if you
want fulfillment it doesn't exist unless
I don't think it exists unless you are
serving other people like I think as
humans we want to wake up and feel like
today is going to matter everybody wants
to wake up and feel like today is going
to matter and means something to
somebody else and some of us you know
you and I we want to impact the world we
want to have a big you know ripple
effect fact that our positivity you know
reaches everybody and other people you
know my wife they just want to serve the
closest people in our family you know
like the 25 closest people to us but in
either case we all want to wake up and
feel like today is going to matter and
mean something to somebody else if you
woke up every day and felt like it
didn't matter if you woke up today and
felt like nobody cares if I show up I'm
not doing anything meaningful my boss
doesn't care about me like it's just a
waste of time like that's the path to
the depression and anxiety and stress
and suicide and all you know a lot of
problems that we have because people
don't feel like most people wake up and
drive to job that they hate they don't
feel like what they're doing matters
where on the flip side if you woke up
and felt like today was going to matter
and mean something then you're much more
likely to show up with energy and hope
and optimism and so I'm trying to do
that for me every time I go and help
somebody I feel better right so like
this is part of like we are we are
interconnected as humans we're we want
to feel like we're going to do something
that's going to mean something to
somebody else what do you think is the
best part about being an entrepreneur
and what's the scariest part if you had
the kind of warn would be entrepreneurs
out
there I think the reason you get into
entrepreneurship uh has to has to be
strong that you're moving towards
something not away from something hating
your job is not a good enough reason uh
having a bad boss is not a good enough
reason having toxic people around you in
your workplace means you should get out
of that but that's not the reason that
go be an entrepreneur because you're
going to work harder as an entrepreneur
than you will yes job right now now
you're you get yes you get to set the
rules and you get to decide what you
want to do but if if you're only in it
because of Freedom that's the wrong
reason you have to be in it because you
want to make an impact you have to want
to serve I I believe that humans are
built to serve I think it's in all of us
I think it's hardwired into into us uh
and that how do you serve well you Pur
comes from your pain that the thing that
you struggled with the most in life
whatever the most painful moment of your
life was helping other people not go
through the same thing that you went
through will be the thing that will fill
you up for life and it will never get
old and so that's the thing that people
need to find I love helping
entrepreneurs because I struggled so
much as an entrepreneur so I want to I
want to now pay it forward and help
others and that's that's everybody so
you need to figure out what's the what's
the going to that you're you're creating
not the moving away from and then how
you're going to serve and if you if you
do that you'll have success I think most
entrepreneurs when they get started
they're doing it for the wrong reasons
because they just don't like their job
and then they're just chasing an
opportunity they don't actually love the
thing but this is a hot thing to do in
2019 2020 2021 so that's what I'm going
to do but if you don't love that thing
you're going to lose um so that's the
biggest mistake most entrepreneurs me
whoever it is that you look up to like
who's who's done the thing that you want
to do if you love Kanye if you love
Steve Jobs or Elon Musk or Oprah or
whoever it is that you look up to look
at their story look at how they got
started it'll do two things for you one
it'll it'll give you the tactics like
what did this person do to become
successful and two it'll give you the
motivation because chances are the
people who you look up to started off
with a lot less than what you currently
have right now uh one of the people I
love looking up to is Oprah she you know
was a sexually Abus growing up she
didn't grow up with her parents uh her
grandmother raised she was so poor that
she her grandmother bought bags of
potatoes and used the potatoes to then
sew it into a dress and Oprah went to
school in potato bags it's like just
imagine showing up in school in a potato
bag as a dress you it's it's crazy and
so it's hard to imagine that whatever
situation you think is so terrible in
your life right now that Oprah had it
you know way worse than what you're
going through and look at what she was
able to do and so people have done it so
getting out of the excuse is in your
head of why what resources you feel you
don't have or what circumstances life is
thrown against you people with a lot
less of than a lot more and so model
their success and go after it what is
the importance of video influencers
watching maybe thinking about focusing
their branding and their messaging yeah
I think if you're a human being you have
a core value there's something inside of
you that is the most important value in
the world something that you place
higher than money and when you figure
out what that is and then you bring that
not just to your business but to your
life the people you hang out with but in
the context of creating a YouTube
channel the content like how do you
stand out if you are another family
vlogger another gamer another
entrepreneur and there's tons of
competition how do you do it it's based
off of what is the single most important
core value that you want people to feel
cuz I want people to feel an emotion
when they watch my videos when they
watch these interviews I want you to
feel an emotion and not just get content
got it so your one word is believe right
it is what's the story behind that how
did you come over that uh it came from
parents they always taught me that I was
I was Evan cast carmichel I could do
anything that I wanted and it's a
message I still pass on to my son and
they just made me feel like whatever I
wanted to do it was possible and to
believe in myself to do it and it's it's
come through my entire life my favorite
movie is seab biscuit it's about this
horse that is too small and a jockey
that's too big and a owner that had no
money they come together it's this
Underdog Story and so anything around
believe just I feel better about now
trans that to a YouTube world when I had
my channel I saw my channel but like my
first video that took off that did well
was this video took me a year to get to
100,000 views on it and I was like I was
so happy 100,000 views for a lot of you
watching it may be more than what you
have right now I was so pumped I made a
video around believe which was my one
word and we hit 100,000 views in a month
and that video now has over 2 million
views and now believe oozes out of
everything that I create so I'm trying
to give you the content that you can use
to grow your business but I want you to
feel out of every piece of content that
you can go off and do whatever your main
Big Goal is I want you to feel believe
out of everything that I create why is
it necessary that's one word for
Branding your business so I think it
comes in two forms I think it starts
with you I think it gives you the clear
perspective on what your brand is all
about I think a lot of times when people
coming up with a brand they don't you
know they're they're picking something
because it looks nice or it sounds good
but it's not coming from a really deep
place of meaning and the brand needs to
mean means something first to you like
you need to be proud of everything that
you're creating and it has to have a has
to have a heartbeat everything you make
has to have a heartbeat whether that's a
creating content or or creating the
service like you do coaching you do
Consulting that has to you have to help
people thrive in in those sessions or
you're not going to be you know happy
about that um and so it it gives you a
frame of reference for yourself first
that then that flows through everything
flows into your entire business how you
operate your company uh you know you
want to bring on people to your team who
believe in similar things as you do if
you're hiring a video editor you know my
video editor wanted to tattoo believe on
her arm before she even met me because
she she you know she believes in the
same thing and so you want to bring
people on who have the skill set but
also believe the same thing that you
believe and if you don't know what you
believe then you'll attract anybody but
if you're really specific on what you
believe then it's easy to bring people
in who are on the same Mission that's an
internal brand most people look at the
external which we can get to but like
that's the internal brand you need the
internal Compass because if the external
is one thing and the internal is
something else you're not going to be
happy you're going to feel like a fake
you're going to feel like you're always
having to live up to something that
you're not the external then is what
people perceive it as what when people
see your your content when people see
your product or service your your
branding your your Instagram and YouTube
and all of that what do they think what
do they feel if it's too complicated
ated you know they won't be able to
share it people people could love your
stuff but if they can't articulate it
clearly to their friends and their
colleagues they're not going to share it
I think of uh corporations that have
their 13 core values that nobody
actually knows nobody shares it because
it's too complicated like if you need me
to remember five things about you to
share it I'm not going to it's just even
if I love you like I'd have to love you
insanely a lot to remember those five
things but if it's if it's one thing
people know me for belief they want more
belief in their life it's you should
talk to Evan you should go watch his
YouTube channel you should subscribe to
him you should check out what he's doing
it's just easy to remember because
people have busy lives it's not that
they don't want to talk about you you're
just making it too complicated you're
introducing too much friction to them
what is the entrepreneurial mindset how
do they think wow I think it I think it
roots from a a dissatisfaction with the
world around us uh entrepreneurs are The
Crazy Ones who see a better future are
upset about something
and then we want to make a change where
I think anybody can pick out something
that they don't like in their world but
the entrepreneurs are the solution
providers they're the ones who want to
find a way to solve it and to make the
world a better place somehow and I think
most of our Global problems could be
solved by entrepreneurs if they're given
the opportunity a feeling that I have
the power to be able to make a change
where I think a lot of people who might
be inside a a corporation or an
organization they see a problem with how
their organization is run if you're you
know you work at a library you see tons
of problems with the library but then
you feel oh I can't do this because I
don't have the power it's not my
position it's not my job title where the
entrepreneurial mindset is I'm going to
find a way to make a difference I'm
going to find a way to make a change if
I don't like something at this Library
I'm going to step up and do something
even though it's not my position uh and
so I think adopting that mindset and
just that ability to feel like I'm
empowering myself I don't need
permission from somebody else to say
what I can and cannot do I'm going to do
something to try to make a positive
impact
and uh one for the individuals in the
organization to feel like they can go
and take that leap and then two for the
leaders of those organizations to
empower their team to take risk and do
something different and not say you can
only do what's inside this box when
people ask like what's the what's the
secret to uh health and I think a lot
lot of people default to diet and sleep
and you know a lot of the typical things
but for at least for me my answer the
secret to health is actually loving the
work that you're doing I think if you
woke up every day and felt like I love
what I'm about to do today I'm gonna go
serve somebody and it's not that sleep's
not important because it is and diet's
not important what it is but I think
there's a lot of people who are in great
physical shape or who have the perfect
you know seep routine or the perfect
diet who who hate their lives yeah where
I think if you actually just if you
really love the work that you're doing I
think that's a secret to a long healthy
happy life and everything flows from
there uh and so connecting to your
purpose understanding how you can serve
that your purpose comes from your pain
you know you mentioned it that you want
to help other people who basically are
struggling with the same thing that you
struggled with and that's the best like
when you find somebody who's basically
the same as you but you're just a little
bit further along on the journey and you
struggled and you suffered and you you
know almost exhausted all the options
then you finally found the path and you
can shortcut that path for somebody else
it's the best feeling ever how do you
push through any of the parts of the job
that are like yeah but it just just has
to get done whether it's accounting or
any any elements that just are not your
jam yeah so you know a couple rules I
guess that have served me the first is
if it has to get done once uh and I need
to do it I'll do it as soon as it
becomes an ongoing thing it's it's it's
a eliminate automate delegate in that
order like does it have to get done if
yes can I automate it if if no can I uh
delegate it to somebody else so you
mention accounting that is probably the
thing entrepreneurs like the least you
know shout out to all the great
accountants out there uh shout out to
the lawyers who review our contracts and
that's a disaster um but yeah I mean I
gave that up that was one of the first
things I gave up uh inside of my video
business editing I didn't want to do
that was I hated editing and Shadow to
all the great editors who love doing
that we've got four or five editors on
our team um and they do great work and
they don't want to be in front of the
camera they want to edit so cool uh and
so if it's an ongoing thing I try to get
it off my plate as quickly as possible
and the path especially at the beginning
is trying to figure out inside my
mission how can I make enough money to
be able to hire team to take away the
things that I don't want to do where a
lot of times entrepreneurs are thinking
just big mission out of the gate which
is awesome and inside that instead of
worrying about how to build a giant
brand out of the gate focus on how do I
make my first 100,000 how do I make my
first half million that then that gets
me money to be able to quit my job do
this full-time give myself some
Financial stability but then also hire
team to take care of the things that I
don't want to do was there a moment that
you recall where this where this Mission
became very clear to you yeah I talk
about it a lot in in my book your one
word yeah
and I had my website and my web before I
had my YouTube channel on my website we
had 100,000 pages of content and all
these big name people WR to the website
and I was trying to figure what my
tagline was what's the slogan for my
website and I I didn't sett all anything
that I liked I had you know over 100
million entrepreneurs help the account
and like all these things and nothing
really lied and I went to go uh Watch
The Steve Jobs movie uh and out of that
I I the word believe came
up and like I really like
believe but then I I can't like that's
too broad Le is too it's like it's it's
ourselves who talk ourselves out from
the Big Ideas not even our friends and
family like you you have a bold idea and
then right away your head tells you why
you can't do it why you're not good that
so and then what like you can't just be
believed but it's got believe in self
believe in entrepreneurs believe it and
like team up with all variations and I
slept on at the next ey it came back any
of just like
believe so I don't know let me let me
test it and so I sent the newsletter out
to my email list is talking about
believe and ended up being the best
newsletter terms of engage when clicks
and my sister said that she saw it and
she had she'd like the newsletter which
is like a compliment that the backand
you sistic nuk that I made a video about
believe and my best video on my YouTube
channel had 100,000 views at the time
took a year to get there and I was so
proud of it 100,000 views is great the
video believe hit 100,000 in a month and
now was in a millions of of views for
that video and so it's not that believe
is the magical thing it's a magical
thing for me and so I I chip toed into
it then eventually went all in on just
okay I'm going to be the belief guy I
still need it for myself and I still
need it out like every time I learn it I
want to go teach other people as well so
my biggest strength is belief and my
biggest weakness is belief to do the
next thing I think the the ultimate
resource is your ability to be
resourceful um the line that comes to
mind is from Steve wnc who co-founded
Apple who said stop thinking about all
the things that you don't have and
instead think about what you can do with
what you do have and I think that's uh
an important line for any entrepreneur
it's easy to look at the million reasons
why you're not going to win there's a
million reasons why you will not win and
and you know Gary and I can sit down and
brainstorm a million more reasons why
you're not going to win uh but there's
like eight why you will and so all I do
is focus on those eight and be as
resourceful as possible on those eight
you don't even now if I'm trying to
build my business you know I have 24
people on my team I've had success with
what I'm doing but I don't have a
thousand people on my team and I can sit
and complain around how I don't have a
thousand people or I can say well I have
24 what can I do with my 24 and that's
always the mindset think about what you
can do with what you do have and
understand that whoever your heroes are
whoever you look up to whoever your role
models are in life whoever's had massive
success chances are they started with
less than what you already have right
now whether you're looking at Oprah or
Richard Branson or whoever it is they
started with less than what you already
have right now and so if they could do
it you can too the only difference is
your willingness to be resourceful we
know what we sell perfect let's use
social media to help us sell more of our
stuff like the the big reason why people
quit is because you feel like you're
wasting time making content and it's not
generating any sales for you and I'm
Mission first purpose first if anybody
is familiar with my content what I do
it's like purpose first and you have to
make money because if you're not making
money you're going to quit on the thing
so how can we make money inside our
purpose instead of having to have some
job that's outside our purpose right so
the next thing to think about if you
know what you're selling or what you are
looking to sell right next is who are
referral partners for us so actually
karms if you look at your business like
who are the types of people who refer
clients to you humans are built to serve
cuz because if you're not happy right
now it's because you're not
serving and that's that's hardwired into
US serving others helping others hits
the same part of your brain is having
food and having sex so it's it's
literally hardwired into you that you
want to you feel good by serving other
people so if you're not happy right now
you mentioned the word depression if
you're depressed and you're not happy
you're not serving either the world
maybe you have a big mission or big
Vision or the 25 closest people to you
you don't have to have some giant
Mission but you have to feel like you're
serving the people who are closest to
you either one if you're not happy it's
because you're not serving and so the
good news is you can always figure out a
way to serve exactly exactly and you can
serve on a on a you know really deep
level which is what the book gets into
of how to figure out how to how to serve
exactly but even just doing an act of
kindness even just doing one nice thing
for somebody else will will make you
feel better ultimately what I want
people to do is if you woke up and you
felt like today
mattered like you woke up this morning
and you felt like today mattered you're
going to make something today that
matters you're GNA you're going to
create something today whether that's a
song or a video or an artwork you're
creating when you're creating something
that has the potential to impact
somebody else's life if you did that
every day you're you're on a path to
happiness the brand is usually the
biggest way to long-term have success
with your company but it takes a while
to build a brand I mean you've been
you've been at it you know lots of
people been added like it takes a while
to build a brand and a lot of people
fizzle out along the way and they don't
know how to generate immediate Revenue
which is where the other two shows come
in uh so if you need to make money this
year or right away like in the next
three weeks you can do it through
YouTube it's just not through thought
leadership content if you're doing
influencer marketing or you're going to
run pre-roll YouTube commercials cool
that's just direct marketing and so you
can do that you just track does it lead
to conversions for you and that's
definitely play that's not where I would
be an expert at
uh throwing somebody on your team who's
just at a university or whatever that is
usually an attempt to build brand right
we're trying to create our own content
somehow to build brand uh it's usually
not a super effective way to do it um
but the direct marketing side is very uh
tangible is huge a lot of people are
doing it a lot of big money is coming
into YouTube because the ad policies are
are stric is but but less strict than
Facebook and Instagram so people are
getting the higher Roi off of you BS in
they are on Facebook and Instagram
what's the point of morning routine at
least for me it's to get a feeling so a
lot of times people will just check the
box like I did this I did this I did
this I did this okay cool but do you
feel ready to take on the day because if
not then there's either something wrong
in your routine or you did it uh
half-heartedly and you got to do it with
more intention um I remember I was doing
an event in New Mexico and uh a woman
was in the front row of my event and I
asked her well what's the most important
part of your morning routine and she
said I do the rosary so she takes out
her her you know prayer uh the rosary
inserts doing her prayers I say well
okay so what's the what's the point of
doing the rosary like well by the end of
it I feel connected to what I'm doing
and ready to go and start my day awesome
how many times you actually feel
connected like by the end you doing the
rosary how much time how many times what
percentage of the days do you actually
feel connected and ready to go and start
the day and she said like
40% so the other 60% she's she's doing
the words she's doing the action she's
saying it but she doesn't feel connected
because she's also stressed out about
something else because she's also making
breakfast because she's also watching
some video because she's she's doing
something else like well there's nothing
wrong with what you're doing you're just
not doing it with the intention that is
required oh great keep doing the rosary
but now focus in on doing it with the
right intention because the whole point
of the morning routine is to get the
feeling so I think a lot of a lot of
people a lot of um a lot of
entrepreneurs a lot of people who are
go-getters and action takers we love the
feeling of just like check check check
we check the box they did it but if you
don't have the feeling of ready to take
on the day with boldness with courage
with service with belief then either go
back and do it again or add something to
your morning routine or or tweak it up a
bit because for me at least the point of
the morning routine is to get the
feeling so you're ready to take on the
day do you ever have moments where you
get out of a
with your
mission uh
yeah not in a big way a lot of micro
like what um saying yes to the it's
usually it usually would involve saying
yes to something that I don't want to
disappoint somebody on but I shouldn't
have said yes I think we get a feeling
of whether something is good for you or
not right even coming here and saying
yes why this like my team is pissed that
I'm here because I'm behind I just came
from Arizona I'm going to Orlando next
I'm going back to Arizona and they like
we have this thing in the middle and
like I we need you on all these Saints
right and they're not H but like I'm now
not doing stuff for my team because this
right uh but it's fine it's all right
talk to you it was great okay we're
going to spend extra time awesome let's
do it right even even our crew here was
helping helping set this up right I was
supposed to do a a a show with Ramy
and and they said well why don't we come
here
I no I didn't know him and I didn't
really know you so like okay well but it
felt right what is your number one tip
or strategy to help us sell more
understand your most important goal and
then create the show that helps you
accomplish that goal like YouTube can
serve you in a lot of different ways
most people think of it just as a place
to be an influencer and build a brand
and and it is if you want long-term
success building a brand and having
people beat a path to your door is huge
but that doesn't happen and you know 30
days uh so if your number one goal is I
need to make sales in 30 days cool start
a YouTube show around Business
Development let's go close so I start
out the book around mediocrity and it
gets it gets it gets pretty angry I
think and pretty pretty pretty
aggressive I want to start the book off
strong I think you know ultimately I
think everybody has the ability to be
great I think everybody has Michael
Jordan level Talent or like whoever your
favorite entrepreneur or person or like
somebody who you think is just amazing
at what they do I I think everybody has
that I think everybody has that ability
you might not be able to play basketball
better than Michael Jordan but you can
be Michael Jordan of something yes I
agree yes Michael Jordan is is special
but he's not that special at the same
time like everything I've done on
YouTube is special but I'm not I'm I'm
just like everybody else I'm not that
special like you could do what I'm doing
you could do it better than what I'm
doing in your own thing don't don't
don't come after me and do believe in
top 10 I'll I'll Crush you on that but
like you could do your own thing right
like people watching you could do your
own thing and so most people settle for
just a mediocre life it's just okay
you're just paying your bills you're you
know you you may not hate your life
totally but it's it's just okay and and
I want I want to shake people out of
that I want you to feel like you know
you have an ability to be a genius like
you already are a genius and we got to
untap that and the best way that I know
how at to start is through
self-awareness and so I think it begins
with core values it begins with your one
word but even if you think the whole
thing doesn't make sense like just
understanding that you could be the
Michael Jordan of something and and you
should be allergic to mediocrity that
it's not acceptable for you to to not
live the life that you want to go off
and live I expect to fail all the
time I expect everything I do especially
at the beginning to not work right if
I'm launching something new I just don't
expect it to do well at the beginning
because it's because creativity is messy
and people put this label Perfection on
it I want it to be perfect but you don't
even know how to make it yet so just get
it out there I value the momentum more
than the
Perfection and so I don't if you're
looking to believe that it's going to
work out that's a big picture macro
concept that any video that I make on my
YouTube channel may not work and if it's
a brand new thing I expected not to work
but it's the belief that if I keep going
it will eventually work right that I'll
figure it out that I'll adjust that I'll
learn something and I'll prove the next
one so I think people need to give
themselves permission to fail at the
beginning for it not to work out and to
not take that personally doesn't mean
that you suck just because your first
song didn't hit it big just means you
learned a little bit and keep going and
if you keep making new songs and every
day you're practicing and trying to get
better eventually will work out and I
just fully believe that I can do it that
you can do it that everybody watching
and listening can do it people just quit
too soon and they're trying to be too
perfect until they never get to where
they need to be I think everybody has an
agenda for you uh your parents your
friends your family your kids like
everybody has an agenda for you and if
you don't understand what your agenda is
for yourself then you'll just be pulled
in a thousand different directions and
never accomplish anything that you
actually want to go off and accomplish
and so chances are whatever the thing is
that you have greatness in whatever you
have Michael Jordan level Talent at uh
it's going to make some people upset you
know even out of love like saying that
you want to go off and do this but uh
your parents don't think that that's the
right thing for you or or nobody in your
family has ever done it it's easy for
them to pull you down and prevent you
from going off and doing the thing that
you actually want to do and so the
common trait of everybody who's had
massive success is being able to deal
with the people around them telling them
that their idea suck that it's never
going to work and you still get up and
you go and you do it anyway for a lot of
people the advice that your parents are
given you is out of love they love you
they just see success differently they
grew up in a different world and so
success to them looks one way and you're
off doing this crazy other path and so
they just care about you and they're
trying to do the best thing that they
think is for you but the the worst
advice you can give somebody is what you
would do in a
situation that's the worst advice you
can give them here's what I would do
well who cares what you would do you're
not me right like never get like the
best advice you can give is try to
understand that person and give them the
answer that will help them even if it's
not the same thing that you would do
right and so I think a lot of people
that's the real trouble spot where
there's people who love you who are
trying to help you and they think
they're helping you but they're not um
because that's what they would do the
thing that anyone who follows you online
will say is that you are definitely
consistent how much do you think that
has played into the success that you
have today I think a lot I was doing an
interview earlier today and uh somebody
was saying that I was really bold like
you're such a bold courageous person I'm
like really I don't know I don't feel
that bold but I am consistent we started
in 2009 and I don't think I've missed an
upload in a decade and so you know tons
of videos just consistently going up so
uh yeah I'm the guy who did not start
super well at the beginning I had 25
subscribers in year one and th000
subscribers in year five and I fast
forward today and you know I've had a
lot more success since then but just
waking up every day and doing the work
and amazing things can happen something
you say that I love is that you can't
out Evan Evan I want to know what you
mean by that yeah I think a lot of times
we we have role models we have mentors
and there's nothing wrong with it I love
I've learned a lot from the people in my
life and people are profiled on my
channel uh but it it's easy to turn into
impostor syndrome to feel like well I'm
never going to be as good as whoever
like you're here starting this podcast
uh and you might look at Joe Rogan or
Tim Ferris or whoever whoever you think
is the best podcaster interviewer out
there but the goal is never to be Joe
Rogan the goal is to be the best Samuel
Apostle and that is an evolution and
even at the beginning if you start
asking Joe Rogen questions that's fine
as a as a you know you're tasting and
testing and getting started but we're
always so worried about chasing our
competition where really the goal should
be to be the best us and so nobody can
out Evan Evan nobody can out Samuel
Samuel and so when people uh will often
share videos with me to say oh look this
person copied your style this person is
doing exactly what you're doing like
that's cool like I don't you're not
going to out me me so if you're just
going to be a elfis impersonator great
like keep doing you but ultimately
everybody needs to find their own path
so I think so many times we're worried
about the rearview mirror and what's
happening behind us as opposed to
forging our own path to say okay how am
I going to be unique what do I love
doing that other people don't and going
all in on that thing as I went through
writing the book I actually did not have
the negative side at all the think of
what you hate because it's not how I'm
wired I never really think negative I'm
always super on the optimistic side uh
but as I started helping out
entrepreneurs a lot of them had a hard
time going positive and finding what
they one was they were constantly
struggling and so I just suggested hey
like okay forget about the things that
make you happy what do you hate like who
do you hate which teacher did you hate
growing up which friend or colleague or
someone at work or classmate did you
just absolutely hate not that they're
wrong or they're a bad person there's
just something about them that you don't
like and some people find it easier to
do that and think of like this is what I
like I hate struggle I hate struggle so
much right and then that's your anti
word and just go the opposite and you
find Thrive and so that was because of
the coaching I did helping different
entrepreneurs oneon-one and finding her
one word that was a nice little addition
to the book in one of the exercises so
if you have a hard time finding it going
positive it may even be easier to go
negative to figure it out Evan you have
a brand new book called momentum I love
the word momentum I think it's the
hardest thing to get and the easiest
thing to lose why the book momentum and
why now brother uh I actually was plan
on writing the book at all built to
serve was my book I was like it's still
the book and then I did a a session with
my now business partner uh Kira we did
add you live together and she kind of
pulled it out of me and uh this idea
just came out like momentum that's
that's the book I often tell people the
only thing they're missing is momentum
like you have the heart and you have the
idea and you have the the willingness to
serve and like you're doing it for the
right reasons and you deserve to make
money what's missing just momentum like
you're overthinking you're over you're
over you're over planning you're just
over over and you're not doing enough
like momentum uh and so she challenged
me to write the book in eight weeks my
first book took me a year to write and
then she said well when are you gonna
start and the book's called momentum
right it's like when of course I have to
start now like I'm gonna start next week
I'm gonna start in a month like no I
have to eat my own dog food and so I
wrote it uh I wrote it like got off the
call with her at 3 pm Eastern and just
started writing and I wrote it in five
days like this book was written in five
days and we ended up having it published
in eight weeks and when you're you're to
Dave's point of like when you're in the
right frequency and around the right
people and hitting the right vibration
like you can create Magic and if you're
not it's because you're in the wrong
frequency around the wrong people and
you have the wrong thinking in your head
too whatever problem you're facing right
now somebody's already solved it and and
a great way is actually to look through
books and find out you know whatever
problem in history that you're facing
right now has already been solved
history repeats itself over and over and
over again it started when I was 19 had
my first software company and I was
struggling and failing and making $300 a
month and not being able to survive and
I hit my bottom and and then I
eventually realized that I'm not the
first guy to try to sell software before
like this has been figured out I just
need to find someone who's done it and
model their success and I looked at
Microsoft and Bill Gates and how he
started Microsoft not how Bill Gates
makes an extra million dollars now it's
not it's not relevant but zero to one
how did they do that that's what I want
to do and I did it through Partnerships
and so I started following what he did
to be successful in his early days and I
started Landing deals and I got my first
check was $135,000 and that to me was
that was amazing that may not seem like
a lot of money but when you're making
$300 a month $35,000 is a lot of money
but more importantly it gave me a model
to then replicate over and over and over
and over and over again and so now my
default is whatever challenge that I'm
facing right now look at who's already
accomplished it and how can we model
their success how do you come up with
your video ideas to keep your Community
engaged that's a combination of what do
I want to make with what are people
asking for and I think that's at the
success of any any successful business
not just a YouTube channel not just a
podcast or a show it's like what do you
love doing with where is there demand if
you take something that you just love
doing but nobody cares you have a
hobby great could be a really fulfilling
hobby but it's just a hobby and if you
take something that everybody wants but
you don't really care about you're never
going to win because you're you're doing
work that you hate and there's somebody
else out there who loves doing that
thing and so don't spend your time doing
work that you hate so it's in that
combination of like what do I love doing
with what do people actually want that
every business can become successful so
for me um we get a lot of feedback from
the audience people leave comments like
hey i' love to see a video on blank and
maybe I know how to do that and maybe I
really resonate with that or maybe I
don't and and then we don't um or just
starts with with me saying I think this
could be a cool idea and then I try to
make that video and put it out there uh
and sometimes they take off and they do
well and we do a lot more and sometimes
it completely flops it's like okay cool
well nobody lik that move on to the next
idea I think the key though within all
of that is we're not so attached to this
thing having to work a lot of times
people when they're first launching
their YouTube channel their business
their podcast whatever we put so much
pressure on the on the launch being
perfect and then if it doesn't work out
we feel like a failure where for me it's
just okay we're going to try that and
we're going to try this we're going to
try that and and something's going to
work and if that that thing yesterday
didn't work cool I've got 18 more ideas
I'm going to try until I find the thing
that does work I think it's a really
hard road to become an entrepreneur how
did you find your Mentor because that's
that's really hard for a lot of people
yeah the trick is when you when you find
somebody who you like who you think
they're ahead of you and you think they
might have something to contribute like
just you have to find a way to get
closer to them so I'll give you two
stories the first with me and Steve uh I
met met Steve through one of his clients
so one of his clients was in Toronto
same city as me and we met at a coffee
shop and he had this idea for the to
pitch on a YouTube video and uh he said
that his agent came up with this idea
he's like agent like what do you mean
agent how do you have an agent you're
like a business guy or like a YouTuber
how do you have an agent because I
thought agents were only for sports
stars or musicians like how do you like
yeah I have an agent he represents like
thought leaders like ah okay can I can I
meet him and uh so he introduced me to
Steve I hopped on the call Steve made me
feel very uncomfortable you know in all
the in all the right ways um and and
that led to me wanting to do more with
him even though I didn't fit the typical
mold mold so it's it's following the
Curiosity right if I never I met I met
this guy in Toronto his name was Shawn
and if I never asked Shawn about the
agent I wouldn't have had that
conversation um fast forward a couple
years ago there was a guy Jeremy who
came to one of my events and he's paid
like 2500 bucks or something to come to
he's 18 19 years old he is working as a
grocery store clerk okay like hates his
life doesn't want to work grocery store
doesn't know what he really wants to do
likes my energy saw my YouTube videos
come to the event it's 3-day event at
the end of the event he messages me says
hey Evan I just want to like how do I
spend more time with you I don't have
any skills yet but I'll I'll walk your
dog I'll I'll clean your car I'll mow
your lawn like I just want to spend more
time with you and I messaged him back
said that's super amazing Jeremy but I
don't like I don't need somebody to walk
my dog or clean my car but um but thank
you um a couple months later I was
driving on my tour I'm driving through
this desert in Texas and I think of
Jeremy and I thought huh maybe I could
teach Jeremy YouTube like I wonder
people keep asking me about YouTube and
they want me to do work on their Channel
and I don't I don't want to do that as a
business but maybe I could teach Jeremy
how to do it and so we got Jer jemy on
the phone that moment oh uh he he took a
little break from his grocery store you
know job and said Jeremy I want to teach
you YouTube we'll start a business
together and I'm away for the next two
months on the road so I need you to
watch all of these videos and learn
everything you can about YouTube and
when I come back if you've done that
I'll help you build a YouTube Consulting
business wow um and we did and now he's
got uh a high sixf fig YouTube business
uh Consulting he he made six figures in
the first 6 months or so of having his
business um and that's from being a
grocery store clerk right but if he
didn't do that Outreach to me I wouldn't
have taken a shot on him either it's
just the the heart and the energy and
the care and he's just I'll wash your
car and I'll clean you know hang out
with your dog I just love the energy and
even though nothing came up in the
moment he was in the back of my mind to
say okay maybe I should do something
with Jeremy and so it's it's trying to
be in a room where you get to talk to
them but then it's it's almost uh
uncomfortable like next ask and showing
your hunger and your commitment level
and then the key thing is when you get
that is you ask one question to the
mentor cuz successful people actually
love mentoring but they also hate
wasting time like time is the most
valuable asset and they love mentoring
but they hate wasting time and a lot of
mentees waste time yeah cuz they don't
do the work so the best thing you can do
if you want if you're trying to get into
a mentorship relationship you ask one
question like what's the one question
you've got to ask Robert qaki one
that you want to ask him right and then
don't ask another question because
that's what people will do they'll come
back and say oh what about this and what
about that it's like no no no like do
the work on the first question that he
gave you an answer for yeah and then go
home and actually do the work and if you
get a result then you can come back and
ask the second question hey I asked you
this I did this now my I've got five
Apartments man thank you from your
advice now I'm struggling with this he's
much more likely to give you a second
answer because of the work you did on
the first one yeah or if the advice
didn't work make sure that you tried it
a hundred times right it wasn't just you
tried you made one phone call and it
didn't work and so the the advice sucked
right because if you tried it a 100
times and you showed the effort then
he's willing to answer a second question
the ability to both recruit team and
recruit clients
based not just off the performance but
the story so in your willingness to
share what you've been
through and the mission that you're on I
think it actually attracts the right
people to you both clients and team
which then that can parlay into
something much bigger if you look at you
know Ed milette came from the financial
World Patrick bavid came from the
financial world now doing things outside
the financial World in a big way follow
them daily yeah that's their background
and still you know kind heavy ties to
the business but you they don't talk
much about it you don't hear Ed and
Patrick talking about that business too
much a little bit but if you were to see
their show you wouldn't think oh this is
the yeah insurance guy right right but
it becomes a a vehicle to get to the
next step you know if
you took the same courage that you
talking about ali and Sanders in and
bring that to your business and your
cont and you're messaging like upfront
it's not just that you're a winner and
you can help them get the deal it's also
the story behind it why would I pick you
over somebody else you have the track
record but other people have the track
record you know is your track record
that much better than somebody else's
you
know maybe compared to Startup for sure
but there's other people who have more
experience than you do but they don't
have your
story and that combination is where you
start to bring on the right people I'm a
big believer that the ideas that come to
you when you're feeling bold
excited powerful inspired like those are
the right ones for you and then we spend
most of our time talking ourselves down
from like why we can't do those things
so if you if you're watching a Craig
video or a Dave video you're hanging out
and you get inspired like that idea
that's the that's the that's your best
version talking to you and you owe it to
you to go do something and take the
first step like you get inspired to go
start your own IG live or your own
YouTube channel awesome like just make a
video people get CAU up like what camera
and what microphone and what am I going
to talk about and then it's like you're
it's over it's over like just press
record and make your first video that's
the first step and that's like people
take a decade to get to the first step
that's the problem so the ideas that
come to when you're feeling bold those
are the right ones for you share with us
some of your tips for creating super
fans yeah I think it starts with
figuring out what is your message what
do you stand for what's what's the one
word that defines you it's it's what I
talk about my first book but what why
should I follow you
like for me I'm about believe so if you
want a shot in the arm of believe you
want to believe in yourself more you're
going to enjoy everything that I put out
you're going to enjoy this interview
you're going to enjoy my YouTube videos
you're going to enjoy my my upand
cominging IG account you're G to enjoy
all that stuff if you don't like believe
you're not gonna like me you're not g
you're gonna tune out you've already
shut off this podcast you know you don't
you're not gonna like what I have to say
and so it's figuring out what is your
message what is so important and
different about you like why are you
doing the thing that you're doing and
then people who like that message will
follow
along most people don't have a message
that they really believe in most people
are just trying to be like somebody
else and that's hard to get like why am
I GNA be your Super Fan I'm gonna be
that person's Super Fan you're trying to
just be like Logan I'm gonna follow
Logan why am I gonna follow you what's
so different and so it's figuring out
what that thing is that's different
about you what your message is that's
super clear and so that I think whenever
I need an injection of like if you're Mr
inspiration whenever I need inspiration
or whenever I need energy like I'm going
to come you to you I'm gonna listen to
your podcast otherwise what's the reason
if I can't if I can't tell somebody why
they need to listen to your podcast or
buy your book or check out your channel
then you're sunk like you need people
talking about you and the message that
you have um now not every message is a
positive one you know some people make
their name off of tabloids and making
fun of people and that's that's that's
escapism so it's either like a people
want to either escape the life that they
hate or they want to go and build a
better life for themselves so you're
either playing on the comedy or on the
making fun of somebody else it's all
escaping the life that you don't have to
think about your life you don't have to
think about growth you just want to shut
off your brain and be
entertained or you want to solve the
problems and you want to build a better
life and so that's where you get the
inspiration and the motivation and
practical uh content so just figuring
out where you lie on that path and then
being consistent about it it that's why
the journey is important too like if
you're saying hey I love I'm about
inspiration I want to inspire people and
everything I do I want to be an
inspiration so I have my clothing line
and I have my books I have my foundation
and now I'm starting my podcast and if
you want to be inspired listen to my
podcast every week and then even when
you're booking guests right you're
booking guests who are going to inspire
people right so like once you get that
identity down then it makes every
decision a lot easier and you give super
fans you give fans a reason to subscribe
and then become super fans what system
or process do you have or or used for
your filming and editing is there
particular
methodology um I think that's evolved
over the years at the beginning I
probably spent way too much time trying
to figure all the stuff out you know my
first video took me a full day to record
because I was trying to it was one video
it's like six minutes it took a whole
day to
record cuz I was trying to get it
perfect and the camera and the lighting
and my friend came in who's a
professional videographer and he filmed
me and I had to memorize my script and
uh over the years has gotten a lot more
streamlined and faster and I've cared
less about it being perfect and more
about me just showing up and trying to
connect more to the heart and less to
the head if we had done this interview
even three years ago I would have said
okay I need to know what are Allen's
questions going to be I want to know
what his questions are uh because I
wanted to have an answer because I would
be afraid of I don't want to disappoint
your audience I don't want you to ask me
some question I'm like oh my gosh I
don't know but what would end up
happening is give a really prepared
rehearsed answer which then doesn't
actually bring the most value to your
community and so instead like I don't
want to know the questions I don't want
to know you know what you're going to
ask me let's just go with it and hope
that um I have enough inside me to be
able to share and
so I wish I had done that sooner you
know if you look back I probably
wouldn't have made changes but like if I
could talk to Evan who starting this
Channel at the beginning he like don't
be so stressed out about saying the
perfect words and having the perfect
lighting and gear an editing process
just go make create and the more you can
connect in your heart instead of your
head and what you think is perfect the
better results you'll actually have
where do we learn to manage people you
don't learn that in school right we
don't learn how to manage people we're
taught usually the opposite in school
which Robert loves talking about it's
like it's cheating it's cheating to look
at somebody else's test or work together
right you got to do all by yourself but
like that's the opposite in business you
have to do it as a team so where do we
learn the ability to manage and delegate
we don't right I think a lot of people
even if you think about school projects
we're usually the ones like hard
carrying the school projects or we're
taught to be like the smartest person in
the room right like you always want to
compete against the person next to you
or Robert teaches us like you don't want
to be the smartest person in the room
you want your team to be the smartest
people in the room it's completely
counter to what we learn in in the
school system so so great you know if
you've never LED somebody before you're
probably not going to be a great boss it
doesn't mean you're going to be a
terrible boss you're going to chew them
out and they're going to hate you but
you need to learn how to actually manage
people and so it's easier to manage
somebody for an hour a day part-time
while you're still running your company
than to have a full-time person who you
now committed to it's very rare that the
first employee at any company is still
there look at employee number one and 10
years later like that person's gone not
because the person sucked it's because
you sucked as a leader yeah like you
don't know how to hire you don't know
how to delegate you don't know how to
manage you don't how to train we think
that we get somebody in and then oh this
person's just going to take off all my
problem you got to you got to train them
you got to Mentor them you got to help
and so it's easier to get started like
that's a skill that you will that will
serve you for the rest of your life no
matter what you end up doing the point
of the podcast is to help people be
unstuck if it's in relationships if it's
in business if it's in the idea that
they've always had that they want to do
something they want to achieve it's to
unlock that potential cool so you're in
a fortunate position in that you you're
starting it from scratch but you're not
you're not starting from scratch right
you you have you have some contacts the
industry you know some people you you
can pull sweaters as a analogy an old
Mentor used to give me okay where like
you're pulling sweaters to get to the
head of the line sure where you know
enough people that you can get to people
you can get to bigger and bigger and
bigger people right so you know there's
people who've used your service you've
gone to events you have connections even
you know after this interview goes up
you can see who follows me an easy hack
is like for current guests see who who
follows them on Instagram and then reach
out to them oh so after this interview
goes live see who follows me on
Instagram and then you can reach out to
them and say hey I had every carac call
on my show I'd love to have you on too
wow my name May mean nothing to many
people but it means something to a few
people it allows you to do you know
Outreach okay but so you can you can
work your way up and you can get you can
get guests on your show at a faster clip
than most people who are just tur off a
podcast cool to what end like how can I
bring you value how can other people
come on and bring Justin value audience
value because that's I guess the work of
the uh that's the brand like what what
are we trying to create here so
unlimited potential okay awesome I love
it I mean I'm all believe so great I
love it is it the guest is it the format
is it people coming on and coaching you
is it like what are we going to do
different on this podcast compared to
all other podcasts out there that you
know have the same purpose as you you
don't have to have it all figured out
either you know on this on this call
right now but that becomes the uh the
ongoing fact why would somebody
subscribe to the channel why would they
watch what you're doing you can get
guess which is again you you're not St
from scratch but if I'm coming on your
show how does this become a different
interview or show than the other ones
that that other people are on that I've
gone on other people's channels and had
you know similar conversations I mean I
talk about belief in potential all the
time so how does it become different is
it about my potential story is it about
your potential story is it about diving
into a specific like and it all comes
from your heart like what do you
actually want to create I don't enjoy
being the center of attention it doesn't
it doesn't um it doesn't do anything for
me but where it started to shift was
well I still want to serve you know like
I still want to feel like what I do
matters to people and that I wake up and
I'm having a meaningful impact and so
whereas I've had to learn to harness the
power of the introvert and and figure
this stuff out as I go but also learn
from other introverts and that okay so I
don't like networking meetings I hate
small talk I don't talk to the guy next
to me on the airplane I all of that
stuff but but I love meaningful
conversations and I can get like I see
Patty an in my calendar like this is GNA
be amazing let's go and so how how do
how do you show up with that energy well
I don't know I'm not I think introverts
still want to serve introverts still
want to have meaningful connections
introverts still want to feel like what
they do matters and the more I can tap
into that than than my energy and
enthusiasm that is in everybody um comes
out so it's just it was but that's that
was years of I wish I knew you 10 years
ago like things would have been so much
better have you had those kind of uh
battles
you join yeah I had one big one and and
after that I didn't have it again uh and
that was when I was 19 when I was trying
to make that decision do I I had all I
wanted to do up to that point was I
wanted to be a banker right this my
dream and I'm in my last year university
and I have opportunities to work at um
Merl Lynch and McKenzie was a strategic
consulting company and they fly me to
New York and put me up in the W of ptor
and like wine and D and all this stuff
to kind of recruit me to try to join
their company and it was the job that I
always wanted the job the job man I'm
talking 80 to
100,000 first year coming out of
University 19 years old traveling the
world doing merges and Acquisitions like
what I wanted meanwhile I've got this
company that's sucking I'm making 300
bucks a month and it was just something
like I don't I don't know what to do
yeah it's confusing uh
and my parents actually were were very
supportive and and said you know what
whatever you do we'll support you you
know they always told me that I was a
cast carmichel my mom's last name is
cast my middle name is cast I'm a cast
carmichel I can do anything that I want
it uh but my friends they were all
jealous they're like what how are you
not how are you even thinking about this
right how are you not just saying yes to
these job
opportunities uh and I was really torn I
didn't know what I wanted to do I didn't
know which path to go in and then the
thing that helped me and the thing that
I still use today whenever I'm faced
with this kind of decision is I think
about not regretting my
decisions and I fast forward to life at
90 or however old I am when I'm like
dying on my deathbed and thinking back
will I regret having said yes or no to
this decision and I could live with
saying no to the job because I knew I
could get another job right but I
couldn't live with giving up on the
company because I didn't know if it
would come by again
and so I gave I said I'll give myself a
year I'll give myself a year I'm going
to try this company and see how if I can
make it take off and if it doesn't I'll
go back into the job market and just
that idea of not trying to live with
regret is then that it was super
difficult at that point like hardest
decision ever to make in my life but
ever since then I just I just think
about it this thing that I'm thinking
about doing now this impossible decision
am I going to regret not doing it and
then that makes the decision easy then I
have to go out and do it what advice
would you give to this person to kind of
I don't know if it's like to shake
things up in their world or just to give
them momentum wow so there's a lot there
uh I would want to know more about the
individual but some generic advice one I
would expect to suck at the start I
would expect a struggle at the start I
think people expect to be amazing at the
start and then they're shocked by how
hard it is when they actually get out
and go uh certainly my case I expect it
to be doing way better
than I I was at the beginning and I was
actually too embarrassed to tell my
friends and too ashamed that like I was
making no money and I couldn't come out
to dinner or birthday parties not
because I was too busy but because that
20 bucks was too much for me to go out
for a night so expect to suck at the
start um I think remembering your why
remembering what you're doing remember
the big ambition that you have I think
if you started a business just to try to
make money you will fail because it's
going to get hard and it's a deep
passion for what you do that helps you
through those tough times that you would
keep doing it even if you weren't making
any money because you just love it soone
it's a it's a part of you what what this
is is a part of you you have to keep
doing it if you stop it a piece of you
dies you like that's what you need to
find and so making money is important
too but it's never number one there's
got to be something more important if
you only did it to make money you're
going to fail the more that you can make
choices
that build self-respect and build
character the more you're capable of
making more choices like that people
think of it as some giant thing like
whatever your goals are I talk to a lot
of entrepreneurs so they want to start
their business but whatever your goals
are your personal your health goals your
Fitness your relationship your business
goals whatever they are it's not just
some one thing one giant goal that you
chase it's the daily minor decisions
that you have to make it's every day you
have this choice to am I gonna do the
thing I said I was going to do or am I
going to not do it you know like am I
going to let myself down again here or
am I going to do the thing that makes me
proud and it's in in these minor
decisions that we have every day that
ultimately leads to you building your
character so I mean you started your
show it's great amazing a lot of people
would love to start a show like you did
a lot of people would love to have
guests on their show as well and they
immediately have that insecurity in
their head come to say well who's going
to listen to me and what am I going to
talk about and which guest is going to
want to come on my show and they've been
on other shows how am I better how am I
different and my show and they've been
different and what that does is shut
down your action to go and create the
show and the more you listen to that
voice the the less action you do and the
more you teach yourself that you suck do
it you're training yourself to not do it
again the next time and not doing it
because this becomes your identity like
I'm the person who has great ideas but
never follows through and that is
something that we have to start to
consciously destroy on the health
Journey well I'm just a fat person and I
can't stick to a diet and I can't do
anything I can't run more than a mile I
can't like and we've created this
identity but all of those things are
fixable but it's not one giant leap
right you don't just get healthy by
going to the gym one day it's the
everyday consistency that you train
yourself for perfectionism is really
just fear you know you're just afraid
right so I try I mean of course I'm
still afraid of many things but if I can
catch it I try not to be or do the thing
that makes me scared but to the Kill
Your Darlings um yeah one of my greatest
fears earlier
on uh in my career
was being an aging rock star and so one
of the things that for some reason
really bothered me was you look at these
rock stars who were big in like the 70s
or 80s or 90s or whatever and they still
go on tour and like wow they're still on
tour like it's amazing that they're
still on tour but they're still still
singing the songs they were singing like
decades ago yes you know like where is
the new stuff like have you had nothing
new to say in 30 years since you
recorded the thing right and right
anytime you're anytime you're uh
judgmental of somebody else it's
self-reflection it's like it's your own
you're worri about yourself not about
like Aeros Smith or whatever doesn't
care about me or my opinion and I don't
really hate on aerosense so it's like if
you are criticizing somebody else is
like well look inside because you have
that same thing that you're criticizing
and I realized it was my fear that I I
don't want to be that like I don't want
to be Evan uh you know 30 years later
still making videos yay but like telling
the war stories of back in 2023 when you
know was on with Sean talking about Tom
Brady uh I want to make new stuff right
I want to make new stuff and I think
I've I've overcome that one um I only
bring up the past when people people ask
me questions about um about the past uh
but that was yeah that was a big thing
that was a big fear of mine early on
getting started it's like I didn't want
to just hold on to my darlings and sing
the same songs over and over and over
again believing in ourselves is being
true to ourselves we're not changing who
we are to serve others we're serving
others as we are right and that's
critical the authenticity the
genuiness how how did you segue that to
salsa dancing so I never learned to
dance growing up I always felt kind of
awkward at a club or whatever dancing
and uh in University I decided okay I'm
gonna I want to learn how to dance and
so there was a there was a ballroom
class that I took with my then
girlfriend not Nina um and we signed up
and took the class and she never really
liked it uh we went couple lessons maybe
a semester and then she didn't want to
do it anymore and it was a kind of class
where you you have to go with a partner
and so I didn't have a partner and I
didn't want to ask another girl to be my
partner when I'm in a Rel it didn't feel
right you can get in a lot of trouble
doing that Evan Ju Just saying yeah yeah
so it's okay so that's the end of that
whatever fine you know there's other
things to do but then when we end up
breaking up one of the things I said was
well I can go dancing again like why
don't I go learn some dancing and salsa
dancing is the easiest dance to be able
to pick up as a solo person so what I
mean by that is when you're dancing it's
part of the culture to switch Partners
all the time so even if you come as a
married couple it would still be normal
to dance with other guys for you and
other women for me which is part of the
cult now some people stay together but
for the most part the culture is very
interchangeable it's part of the energy
I would imagine yes and borom is very
specific it's like You' got your One
partner C is more of a street dance and
I just fell in love with it now on paper
I'm Too Tall I take big steps I don't
speak Spanish I didn't learn this
growing up uh you know all of the things
that you we could say are logical
reasons why you shouldn't do it and I
think a lot of us live in the world of
well I I can't do that and I shouldn't
do that without ever even trying and I
wasn't even very good at the beginning
either because a lot of those reasons
but I just loved it you know there's
something about like this is amazing I
had to I I signed up for two different
schools to go learn because I was a slow
learner at it but just to pick it up and
and I love meeting people I love the
connection I love I love I think also
learning a new skill that you thought
was too difficult also is how you build
belief in yourself to say well I
couldn't I can't do that but then you
see that you can raises your belief
level to do other things so that made me
a better entrepreneur how could someone
like take their business and evolve it
with them what kind of things could they
do just think about what is it that you
want to create so for for example I had
a successful website it was off my name
we had lots of successful people writing
for it um making money off advertising
coming to the site I was getting
restless and so I said I'm gonna try
something new I'm gonna I want to go to
YouTube I'm gonna try that and I tried a
whole bunch of stuff like you try things
you don't know at the beginning it was
going to work out or not so I tried
YouTube as one of many things and I
liked it and so I kept doing it and then
I kept doing it and I evolved my
business a lot of people don't even know
me from my website they only know me
from my YouTube channel yeah right
because we we've blown up there but if I
get bored of YouTube like the minute
that like I like talking to you this is
great Michael's Michael's doing an
interview I love it let's get on board
the minute this feels like work like
it's oh man I gotta talk I got to do
another interview this sucks I I need to
quit I need to do something else because
you will never win doing work that you
hate okay and so the minute that this
feels like a job I need to stop and go
off and do something else what is it
something else you know like just ask
yourself what what what would I do what
do I want to do what do I want to work
on you may not have the perfect vision
yet for like the final goal but find
some small thing to get started on I
think everybody can can lean in and
learn whatever they want to learn um I
had the Good Fortune of having some
great parents on the they're on the wall
behind me here I'm eight or nine years
old and those are my parents there and
they would always tell me hey you having
caric like you do anything you believe
that you can and so they helped instill
that in me um I think the whole you know
the Gary V's point about are you born
with it well what were you doing at 7
years old like were you doing lemonade
stains and garage sales and taking some
initiative um but if you weren't don't
feel like oh my gosh now I can't be an
entrepreneur it's it's so much easier
now than ever to start your own business
or to lean in on the thing for sure like
I believe everybody's got Michael Jordan
level genius at something like you're
the greatest in the world at something
and you just don't believe that you are
and you don't believe in your dreams
enough to go chase them down but you can
whether it's being an entrepreneur and
beli in your business whether it's
believing in your health Journey that
it's possible whether it's you know
climbing Mount kilero or losing 100
pounds or like whatever the thing is
that you'd love to do it's it's possible
people like you have done it and that's
where a lot of people get stuck is like
well it's Poss like somebody else has
done it but I can't do it because I'm
whatever and my story early with the
YouTube stuff was um I'm an introvert
I'm shy so I'm I'm not going to make it
you know but I'll keep making content
because I'm serving but I'm I'm never
going to be the big name because I'm too
introverted and too shy and I still am
by the way it just doesn't come out when
I'm doing shows like this um but you can
you know you can whatever whatever that
story is in your head it's totally
fixable and other people you know like
you have done it and it just comes down
to starting to change what you put into
your head I think that's the biggest
thing of all that's why I make so much
content
because if somebody felt like their
health Journey was impossible you know
it's like you know J you don't
understand I was impossible you know
understand I've been like this and my
family has been like this and it's just
not possible and I've tried a million
things and just nothing works and it's
it's never going to happen Jay just
that's that's who I am right if they
spent a month with you you know because
you're more confident in their ability
to get healthy than they are in their
inability to get
healthy and same thing with me if
somebody's hanging out with me for an
extended period of time if we were
hanging out together uh I'm going to get
a lot healthier
probably and you're going to be making
more YouTube videos man we're going to
get you on there and and crushing it
because whoever is more confident wins
and so the problem is we're surrounded
by people who don't believe in our
dreams who tell us that it's not
possible and we're also feeding our mind
with things that keep us stuck where we
are and if you want to change something
it's totally possible but it starts with
actually changing um that environment so
that you have a you have the crutch like
to get going to get you out of the
Starting Gate for people who don't know
what their direction is where they want
to go you said try different things
until you find something that works for
you like can you elaborate on that or
yeah at the beginning it's it's a messy
process because you you grow up in a
circle and it's getting easier with
YouTube and internet Etc but uh if you
grew up I think of me growing up who did
I know it's my parents my family my
school you're kind of restricted by your
environment now at least we have YouTube
videos and you can learn whatever you
want to learn there's people out
there when you're struggling to figure
out what your career should be or what
your next move should be
I think you'll have moments in life
where you have absolute Clarity you know
like maybe you're in a moment now of
absolute Clarity I want to get my
podcast actually like kicking ass yeah
right so that's where like Blinder on
and go kick ass on your podcast right
you don't need more you don't need to
get into nfts and like some Ai and crazy
stuff like go kickass in your podcast
when you have Clarity and there's other
moments in life and it's not just a per
like you have moments in life where you
don't know what to do
next you sell your podcast it blows up
you sell it and you're done it's like oh
wow what do I do and that's where you
expand open to say okay I need to try a
bunch of stuff to see what connects with
me so should everybody be an
entrepreneur no but should everybody try
yeah because how do you know you know
should everybody love sushi no but
should everybody try yeah because how do
you know what your favorite food is if
you only eat pizza and hot dogs all day
how you started to create your YouTube
channel because me myself along with
many other YouTubers out there are
people who want to build their YouTube
following H how what do we do how do how
do we start to build and grow our
YouTube channel one is you just start I
think people are in their head too much
I think
people they're trying to be perfect
you're you're some big impossible plan
up in your head and then as a result you
don't do anything so you need to start
you need phone film your phone up turn
it sideways and start the film and post
your first video right what
Marlo first video is gonna be terrible
like thing ever in your life like you
got up on a bicycle and you fell off you
know you didn't just get up and ride so
don't expect to get on YouTube and be
great on camera you know you you could
have great like even you you've got
great speaking skills and you're great
with people and you love interviewing
you love talking it's still a learning
process to get great in front of the
camera some people can short shortcut
that path but it's still a path and so
just start get out of your way stop
being perfect expect it to suck and just
start two I would say you need to be
consistent so it doesn't matter where
you start where you start is not going
to be where you finish but you have to
move and you got to move consistently
and so there was a great quote I think
it was Will Smith but was talking about
how I'm not responsible for where I
started you know I was born where I was
born I can't change that but I'm
responsible for where I finish I get to
control where I go in life no matter
where I started and so people blame
their start and then they don't move but
it's like it's on you doesn't matter
where you came from you you can go
anywhere uh and so consistency you got
to practice you got to get better you
got to make daily content if you want to
get good at something if you want to if
you want to be Oprah Winfree level
Talent at something you have to do it
daily you know if you if you are making
a video a week you're just never going
to get world class at that thing just
just like anything else if you if you
did anything else once a week you would
never become world class at that thing
might get decently good if you want to
be a chef and you're only practicing
cooking once a week you're never going
to be the oer Winfrey of cook of of that
right you're never going to do it so you
need to practice more so one just start
start with what you have start
immediately today like happy New Year
let's start right now today we're going
we're not waiting and then every day you
need to practice you need to practice
practice and you will slowly get better
how do you create a business from all
this that you've been doing and then it
becomes something quite quite quite
quite REM
remarkable yeah I think there's lots of
ways to win I think it's more what do
you want to do so I like helping people
so I like I like doing courses but not
just a course but I like I like training
I like I like having somebody in front
of me I like not just here's this course
I never have to see you again I like
seeing the person and coaching them and
guiding them even just before this I was
I was leading my community and it it
actually used to be a course but then I
stopped it as a course and turned it
into a membership because people are
using a course but I never got to see
them I didn't get the I didn't get to
see the results of what they were doing
and now I get to meet people every week
and see what they're up to and how I can
help but that's that's not necessarily
the best way to do it it's what do you
love doing so you could sell courses you
can sell Consulting you can sell your
products you can sell your services you
can sell your books you can sell your
speaking you can sell your hosting like
there's so many things you could sell
what is that you actually want to sell
that you love doing but I think it's
really important that when you are
getting started that you actually think
about how can you turn this into a
business how can you so that you're not
just wasting time like I I could have
grown grown a lot faster in the early
days of my channel too if I thought
about it like a business and there were
less opportunities there are less ways
to do it compared to right now but um a
lot of people just oh I just want to be
famous okay but how are we gonna make
money doing the thing that you're
creating because if it's just a hobby
most people will probably quit if you
can't figure out a way to make money
most people will probably quit on the
thing and so it's like how do you you
have your purpose and your mission and I
love it yes and inside of that how can
we start to make money as soon as
possible so that you can stay dedicated
to it I'm writing a new book about
finding your purpose and turn into a
business and then I included the last
chapter on how to make money because I
think a lot of people feel icky
or nasty about trying to well I just
love helping these people so I can't
charge for this I think it actually is
selfish not to charge for it I think it
becomes your your obligation that you
have to charge for it not to everybody I
think you they'll always be a percentage
if it's 10% or 20% of people who who get
in for free because they can't afford it
but
if you don't learn how to make money
from your purpose then it will always be
a hobby and you'll always have to do a
full-time job to then support your hobby
where if you actually made it a business
and learned how to make money use doing
it serving people in an ethical you know
life-changing positive way then you can
reach more people you can build a team
you can scale up now instead of as maybe
as a hobby you can hit 10 women a month
wellow hobby but if you have a business
and now you're you're building a team of
amazing women who all want the same
thing maybe now you're reaching millions
of women W so I think it I think it's
your responsibility to to turn that into
something that then can create a ripple
effect greater than just a hobby on the
side how you can model success this is
what saved my business when I wanted to
quit at my company my first software
company and then I realized that you
know what I'm not the first guy to try
to sell software for like somebody has
figured this
out if I just learn from that person I
can apply those strategies to my
business and so I modeled Bill Gates who
started Microsoft and I've never met
Bill Gates but he saved my company and I
looked at the strategies of how did he
start Microsoft not how does Microsoft
grow now who cares it's a huge company
but like start how did he start zero to
one that's what I wanted to do and I
modeled him and I applied that to my
business and we started to grow and so
whatever dreams whatever goals whatever
business you have somebody's already
figured it out may not be exactly what
you want to do and that's good because
you're different you're an entrepreneur
you're going to put your own twist on it
but people have already figured it out
and so understanding what they did and
trying to break down their success could
be really helpful so that if you're
hustling and grinding you're spending
your time on the right things that will
help you as opposed to the things that
aren't leading to
success so so when you say model after
them you you mean like you don't
necessarily have to meet this person you
can just read their books or watch their
interview is that how you learned from
from Bill Gates for example yeah so
there's two kinds of mentors there's the
regular mentors that people think about
where you go for coffee and they're you
know they're local you can go meet them
and they break down your business uh and
I never had that right like my parents
taught me so much about life and being a
human being but never about business and
nobody in my family was an entrepreneur
and so I had nobody to go and have
coffee with I went to my banker and said
hey can you help me with my business
he's like well do you need a loan like
no I don't know do I need a loan I don't
know he's like yeah you're not really in
the right place like I didn't know
anybody and so I Look To What I Call
aspirational mentors these the people
who you aspire to be like or aspire to
learn from and some people may have
already passed on and you'll never beet
them like I have Steve Jobs up on my
wall I'm never going to meet him
obviously um and a lot of the people
behind me uh some I may meet one day or
some passed on uh and so I would look at
two kinds of what I call aspirational
mentors the first are in your industry
whatever you want to do somebody has
done it you want to be a successful
YouTuber there's lots of people who've
done it Go and model them see what they
did the more uh successful they are the
more information there is on them
whether it's interviews or books or
magazine articles like their story is
somewhere and again look to how they got
started as opposed to what they're doing
now because it's a different scale and
then the second kind are just the people
who you look up to you know if if I love
Oprah Winfrey I can learn something from
her even if I don't want to have my own
talk show you know if you love Michael
Jordan you could learn from him even if
you never want to be a basketball player
like the way that he works and his
hustle and effort and he's in the gym
you can apply that to your life and to
your business even if you never go on to
try to become an NBA player so those two
things the people who have done what you
want to do maybe you hate them but you
can still learn from their success right
and just do it your way and then the
people who you just really look up to
and really admire and say one day I want
to have that kind of impact again
understanding how they got started and
modeling their success to help you get
your breakthrough I've had people who
leave my channel because I've made
videos on Trump I made videos on on
Clinton the Clinton the Trump one well
the Trump one was one of my favorites of
yours as
well great I mean you're people are very
in their in their bias camps but I I
like that some people are crossing over
just just the willingness to learn I
think that's how you actually solve
problems absolutely the guy who grew up
thinking black people were the nword and
now is willing to learn like now we're
we're changing perspectives we're
getting somewhere I didn't set out to
try to solve racism but now it's a
little tiny piece of of the solution
absolutely um I love it so like somebody
had
enough uh Equity or confidence in
me that their entire background growing
up with their parents and saying like
these people are the worst humans alive
and you can't learn anything from them
but Evan suggested that I watch his
video he's put up on this channel for a
reason that brief moment of confidence
LED this guy to watch the video and now
he he changes perspective um that's I'm
proud of that I'm happy that I did I'm
proud of myself for that even though I
may lose some people who who will say
never profile a black person on your
channel they got nothing to teach you
that's right like I'll lot those people
okay but maybe I'll convert some of them
over absolutely absolutely and it's very
common that this is part of my ninja
whole strategy behind the channel that's
evolved my ninja strategy is people come
in who to find people who look like
them it it just is like like guys will
gravitate towards guys women towards
women Tech entrepreneurs towards Tech
all of it whoever's like you you want to
go and learn it's just natural yeah but
I want I want to have those people bring
you wi and then introduce other people
who don't look like you who don't come
from the same industry or the same
background and challenge you to try to
learn from that person I think that's
where the real learning comes and I
think that's where tolerance and
understanding and patience is built what
do you sell like what's the main thing
that you want to
sell uh like um right now I have my
books I don't have many many other
things maybe I could come up with many
other things but now I have my books and
I I am a speaker so but I haven't been
speaking quite much I I am in Europe
haven't been much further on
out cool so anything that you want to
sell should be a series on your channel
so if you want to sell books then the
best thing to do is think about people
who can recommend your books and have
them as a guest on your
show so we're using the show for
business development so who can push a
lot of books and it might be
entrepreneurs it might be other
influencers it might be people from the
book Community it might might be uh book
agents anybody in the book world people
with a big list that they might send it
to people who run book clubs right how
do you have them as guests on your show
and we we almost don't even care how
well the video does in terms of metrics
on YouTube Facebook whatever it's free
to build a relationship so that they get
to know you love you trust you and your
book becomes the next thing that they
use in their book club right if you made
a list of the top 500 book clubs in
America and then reached out to all of
those leaders who run the book clubs and
have them as guests on your show you're
gonna get a lot more people reading your
book oh okay being intentional what
skills does someone need to get into
this area of wanting to be an
entrepreneur what does it take I don't
think skills are the problem I think I
think you can learn anything if you have
a a commitment and passion to learn um
learn is your one word you know I think
I think learn the desire and willingness
to to go through crap and learn and get
better you could you could kick up
anything and I think I'm the Testament
to that in that I suck at the start of
my channel if you go back it's
embarrassing watching my first content
it's really really bad but I just kept
learning and said I can get better I'm
gonna improve I'm gonna keep working I'm
gonna keep getting better and and it
worked and so more than any specific
skill I think it's the mindset it's it's
the desire to learn and understand that
I can do better if you take that into
any field uh and match it with some
self-awareness I think you're set like
there's so many different ways to win as
an entrepreneur there's so many
different ways yes you may not win the
same way that Gary ve win and so to have
the self awareness to know hey I'm I'm
Mara I'm great at talking to people I'm
going to do a talk show and then you can
model success and you can learn from
Oprah and you can learn from Larry King
and you can learn from all the great
talk show host and model some of their
Styles and every time you do that you
learn a little bit more to be a better
Mara and keep growing and keep getting
better what do you think would gravitate
towards negativity a lot more when we
know it doesn't make us feel good
because it definitely drains you it
causes an impact I think it's biological
it's like it's like from the history of
US struggling right has to be you I mean
I don't know I don't not I'm not a
scientist and I don't have all the
answers there for sure but but like why
do we slow down and look at a car
accident even if it's on the other side
of the road totally you can get hit by
looking at somebody else a fight breaks
out on the street it's like you're you
know you want to see what happens like
where we I don't know where it comes
from but like it it it definitely is
that people would
rather um consume negative things like
if I my first video was the top 10 rules
for Kanye West and was positive things
you can learn from Kanye if that was a
negative like top 10 stupidest things
Kanye has said it would it would do so
much better because I think I think if
I'm looking at it from the perspective
of what I do is like we we would rather
see people fail than than try to build
ourselves up right you know I was like
oh look at D she she's got her podcast
and she's been on movies and look at her
building her life and she she made it
out and now she's in LA and she's such a
big deal and y y y and it's easier for
me to try to tear you down and want to
see you fail then for me to say huh like
maybe I can fix my life maybe I can go
to La too maybe I can start a podcast
maybe I can and and whatever the things
are that you know jealousy is really
just um ins inspiration that's been
mutated oh wow if I if I'm jealous of
you I'm actually inspired by you but I
don't know how to handle it so I take it
negative
totally so it's easier for me to tear
you
down than for me to try to work on
myself because I don't have to do any
work that way right it's like oh yeah
but then yeah but she like totally sold
her soul to go do that and she and I'll
make I make up some stuff that like
doesn't even make sense but it allows me
to stay where I'm at where I am right so
that's why a lot of a lot of even our
friends and family will often say not to
go do something because if you go off if
you go off to LA and you becoming a
movie star and you start meeting people
what does it mean for
me you know like you left me behind and
and now my life sucks because you're
showing what's possible and I'm living
in a fake reality I don't want to accept
that so it's not possible you must have
had to do something super
scammy terrible yeah like you killed
somebody or whatever you know you hide
someone in the closet and it's not
coming out yeah so I think that's like
it we don't doing work on yourself is
hard very learning new skills and making
new connections and going to a new
country or new city is hard it's really
hard and we don't want to do hard things
but your great life is on the other side
of of hard things and so when we see
somebody else who looks like us comes
from similar
background we want to find a reason why
that person should not be successful
we'd rather hate on them than Be
Inspired not everybody but a lot of
people yeah because we want we prefer to
stay stuck than the grow if you were
looking at me and saying Andrea you got
to Define your Niche you got to choose
one or the other or is there a way to
emerge two things into one in your
opinion so if you're looking at your
audience and picking your Niche what I
what I love to do is build around a core
value so if you do if you're looking at
health and
spirituality those are not mutually
exclusive MH like you can't have health
without spirituality and you can't have
spirituality without Health right I mean
like they go together and so the trick
in like what is your Niche is like what
is the Andrea brand well it's about
what's on what's on top of that that
makes it all make sense so uh if you are
only talking about spirituality that had
no connection to health and only talk
about health that had no connection to
spirituality then those could live as
two separate YouTube channels and
products and Brands but one it's a lot
more work for someone like you to manage
right like now we got to manage two
social media accounts across everything
and it's also less of an expression of
who you are because you're always
limited by I can't talk about this stuff
because I'm only focused on X and so the
exercise that I like to go through with
people is like what sits on top so if
you had to think who does you know what
is Andrea stain for that's spirituality
is part of it and health is part of it
and maybe something else is part of it
too but what sits above like what what's
the mother word
where spirituality and health are
children how do you feel
about this kind of like world that is
going spitting so quickly with
information how do you find that Focus
to be like okay I have my faith but it's
overwhelming like what how do you find
that kind of place so first step like
the first step for me is flipping it to
get excited so when something new comes
out it's like okay I'm excited to I'm
excited go learn that thing AI comes out
cool let's go let's go learn about AI
it's like expecting to suck at it I
don't know anything about AI I don't
know how to program AI I didn't know how
to do anything inside of AI and okay
let's go learn we're we're filming this
video on the on the the day after
Instagram or Facebook just launches
threads right right so threads just come
out it's a Twitter competition and most
people are like oh my gosh threads
another social media thing why do we
need another place to go and doom scroll
on and great like I'm a let me learn
about threads this is exciting I just
try to teach myself that when there's
something new let's go learn it it's
exciting because the rate of change is
not going to go slower right I agree so
so this becomes your key uh adaptation
technique is that anytime something new
comes out get excited go learn about it
this is how you can start to win and for
anybody who is earlier on in their
Journey
whenever something new comes out that
actually becomes your secret hack to go
off and win so if you're trying to get
started and you're on Twitter it might
be hard for you to to win right now
because people have already been it
doesn't mean that you can so you start
you start creating great but go to
threads it's brand new it's all the
people who are on Twitter like don't
want to go to threads because they built
up Their audience all the people in
Hollywood didn't want to go to
YouTube right like where's Brad Pitt's
YouTube channel he should be crushing
right now toally because he doesn't want
to start over right this is the problems
like people don't want to start over and
I don't know anything about Brad Pit no
shaded Brad uh but like some people make
the jump like Will Smith make the jump
and like starts blowing up on YouTube
but a lot of people don't a lot of
people stick to one platform and then
they they slowly become irrelevant and
so when something new comes up this is
your chance to go off and win like you
might not beat Joe Rogan at podcasting
but you can beat him on threads or you
can get close to him on threads and a
lot of the people who are are winning in
that first platform just don't want to
go and start over on the second one and
so this is your chance to get ahead and
so whether it's AI whether it's threads
whether it's an update to the YouTube
algorithm whether it's whatever the
thing is there's more
coming and there and there's more coming
too so training yourself to be the
person who gets excited for new changes
because that's your chance to go and win
and have a bigger impact make more money
like whatever actually drives you spread
more faith right whatever actually is
driving you this is your opportunity to
go off and do it and so for me that's
always been the default where like okay
why I don't it's always been a default I
think I've trained myself um to get more
excited about the new things that are
coming up uh and I just go in with a
student mind expect to suck you know
like I don't somebody asked me about
threads today like hey what's your
thread strategies like I don't know I'm
two days in like I'm trying to figure it
I don't even know what this is yet I'm
I'm maybe not the smart person but I'm
I'm trying to understand it as we go or
when some new AI tool drops okay let's
understand what the heck this thing even
does and learning how to use it so but
it's just getting excited about it and
putting in a little bit of effort to
learn how to do it because so many
people they just get stuck on I don't
know how and it's new and scary and so I
don't do anything where really you're
actually not that far away from making
momentum if you just put in a little bit
of effort are you of the opinion then
that if somebody has a job but they have
a feeling that they want to be um an
entrepreneur but they're afraid of
leaving their job are you of the opinion
that they should uh take a take steps
towards that and and if you have a
feeling for something try
it and just see and expect to suck but
at least you tried and you can see you
know do you want to go off and do it
again you had a feeling in in the coffee
shop to come and ask me to connect if
you didn't follow the feeling that would
have been it like have my my breakfast
with Joe and then CIA and off right and
I may never see you again you had the
feeling you followed it and it may not
always be good like maybe I'm an maybe
I'm an ass maybe like dude get out of my
face you're weird stalking me out of the
bathroom right like maybe like you don't
know you don't know what would happen
but you have a feeling and you have to
follow the feeling cuz otherwise you
teach yourself that the things that come
to you are not great cuz if every time
you get an idea and you don't follow
through you're teaching yourself that
your ideas suck versus I have an idea
I'm going to give it a shot that's a
great identity to start to build it
doesn't mean go mortgage your home to go
start a podcast Studio like expect to
suck and find the smallest possible
thing to just go and get started so
somebody who's working a corporate job
that hates their life okay you're you're
never going to win doing work that you
hate so so longer term something has to
change it doesn't mean go like take a
flamethrower to your boss's office or
something now like you need the money
you need the cool awesome but longer
term like we have to make a change
somewhere cuz you will never be great
doing work that you hate you're never
going to make the money you're never
going to be happy if you're doing work
you hate every day so how you going to
get out of that hole that you're in is
it going to be somebody else telling you
what you should do with your life that's
going to be like you have ideas for what
you it'd be cool if I could do this okay
go give it a shot try it see if you
liked it your first podcast sucked cool
and you get better like you're better at
eight episodes in than I was at like 300
episodes in right so but you try and so
I think if you have the feeling you want
to teach yourself that you come up with
great ideas and and they're worth at
least giving a shot to instead of just
saying you know there's sushi on the
table I don't like sushi without even
giving a shot because it sounds gross
like if you had to explain what Sushi is
raw fish with with fish eggs and seaweed
with rice and super spicy mustard
that doesn't sound appetizing right like
why would anybody eat that but you eat
it I like to sh with you guys but but
you don't know until you try it so like
you're judging things before you're
trying it and especially when it's
yourself you're judging your ideas
before you even try it you're building
uh the belief that your ideas suck and
that you suck and then you stay stuck
and so I I at least you know encourage
myself to try to flip that that I have
ideas that saying yes to you okay let's
go I'm not going to judge it let's go do
it a lot of people tend to say put
others before you put yourself and for
me I've always thought that wasn't the
necessary correct way for me to operate
I know that when I put myself first when
I take care of my health and when I make
sure that I'm living in alignment with
my dreams I serve others better then
versus putting them first and then me
suffering and so for you has that been
something that's been natural to you I
think it's all learned
behavior uh I think my parents started
me off early with just how they lived
and and being an inspiration I think
humans are built to serve period like I
think if you're not happy in life it's
because you're not serving somebody gota
and some people are built to serve the
world like chances are the two of us
we're built to serve we want to have a
big impact we want our our reach to be
wide we have a message that needs to be
heard yeah uh but some people are just
bu to serve the 25 closest people to
them perfect my wife is more like that's
it she wants to she's still in contact
with her friends from kindergarten but
but doesn't have a message that she
wants to share with the world that's
right still buil to serve if you're not
happy because you're not you're not
serving others so the it's the same
thing when you're happy you're you're
capable of serving more people when
you're growing when you've taken another
step on the staircase you can pull more
people up to join you on that
step but if you're stay at the ground
level you can't you can only help people
with things you've gone through and
grown through right so the more you grow
and learn the more you can pull people
up and and help them and that's
ultimately what's gonna like I said your
purpose comes from your pain the more
you struggle and suffer and then grow
the more you'll be able to help other
people go through that same thing so I
see them as the same
thing investing in yourself and learning
getting better and struggling allows you
than to help others but it's based off
of a default premise that people are
good like I believe humans are good and
and that we're built to serve that's
amazing and that if somebody's doing
something that's negative or wrong or
insulting or imagine if you assume that
so for example in La my car was
everything my car was stolen I was on my
I was on my tour um they stole my gear
my signs my wallet my phone like they
stole everything in the car giant
Suburban
raed wow in in a private parking lot um
I think those people are good people who
are built the surf like whoever stole
from my car they're good people who are
built the surf I just believe that how
do you balance your your home life your
work life what does balance look like to
you do you do you have a routine can you
tell us a little bit about it yeah I
think
ultimately My Philosophy is your actions
have to map to your Ambitions so what
are your Ambitions what do you want to
create what's the what's your perfect
dream life I think part of being an
entrepreneur is we get to pick what we
do I mean that's why we become
entrepreneurs we want to create the
schedule that we want for ourselves so
what does a dream life look like for you
and it's not going to be all day working
you don't want to spend all day work on
your business um you also don't want to
spend all day with your kids and you
don't want to spend all day with your
spouse so what does that balance and mix
look like for you and and that's a very
personal question I think part of where
we struggled is We compare Our Lives to
some body else it's like oh well she's
such a super mom and she's doing all
these things and so I suck because I'm
not doing it like she's doing or like
he's doing it where this is a very
personal question and
so what I do is uh I have different
dates through different things so every
morning I'll start de with my morning
routine part of that includes if we're
talking family time part of that
includes me walking with my wife so this
morning we walked the Whole Foods we
took the dogs out it's starting to get
warm here in Toronto Canada which is
amazing uh grab the Americano from Whole
Foods walk back and just set up our
morning what are you working on today
what you know how was your sleep just
connecting grounding getting some sun in
our face getting some fresh air hanging
with the dogs like I like just that
connection in the morning to Nature and
to my my pets and my wife and you know
it's a half hour walk um and then from
there I'm mostly working like today's
been back to back to back calls and
podcasts and training and just work work
work work work work work uh I have five
minute in between and my wife works with
me she's in the other room I saw her
outside on the balcony with the dog so
pop in say hi give her a kiss come back
like little micro moments like that but
for the most part it's just work um and
then different days different different
actions today's we're filming this on a
Thursday that's my public facing day
where it's non-stop interviews and
podcast we'll do something every night
to hang out I'll spend some time um just
with my wife usually watching something
relaxing with the dogs on the couch kind
of thing I'll spend some time with my
son uh off and like playing Minecraft or
something fun that he likes to do um and
then that's usually Monday to Friday
weekends are different story Saturday is
Funday and so Saturday we always do
something for the family that's not not
work rated and not uh admin related so
we're not going grocery shopping we're
not doing uh you know condo cleaning or
house cleaning or whatever but something
something fun like there's a street
festival or we're going to go for a hike
outside or we're going to try a new
restaurant or just something that we
want to do and then Sunday is family
admin day where that's all of the fold
the laundry and clean up the office and
you know like whatever you have to do to
kind of
run I love this run run our
lives my biggest challenge on a
day-to-day I'd say now is not accounting
or doing um you know grunt work or
things I don't want to do it's more
pushing harder you know I think good is
the enemy of great and so things are
really good and and it's honestly great
I mean if you look at a a Global
Perspective everybody listening to this
show is in a great like you have
internet you know globally you're you're
way ahead of a lot of people um you have
food you have a bed so you're you're way
ahead already of a lot of the world but
but you could do more and that's the
biggest push that's why I need Jay-Z in
my ear and Oprah Winfrey in my ear and
and Steve Jobs in my ear and these
people that's why I make the videos I do
because it's easy to wake up and just
keep doing the same it's hard to wake up
and push yourself to do something that
you haven't done before to to believe in
the next version of what you could
become and that's um that's an ongoing
struggle what is your
philosophy uh in terms of as you studied
all these people what do you think for
those listening what are some of the
core elements of success that would be
useful to our listeners if you will
so I think the the number one rule that
comes up consistently and we've we've
covered people who are I started just
entrepreneurs and we've expanded to
athletes and musicians and innovators
and politicians and like anybody who's
had success from any Walk of Life the
number one thing that it all that they
all have in common is the love for the
work that they're doing of yes loving
the the results but like loving the
actual
work often even when it doesn't make
sense for a lot of these people starting
up they have this passion for XYZ but
didn't make sense like there was no
business model attached to it I don't
know how it's going to work out and so
making the big decisions with the hard
and not the head you make the big
decision with the hard and then use your
head to help figure out how you're G to
make it work is a consistent theme
across um all the people that we
profiled uh at some at some degree
you're going to have people who will
will hate on your idea will tell you
that it won't work especially the bigger
the idea you have the more people are
going to hate against it you know like a
lot of people would say TJ we don't have
greatness within us come on man like
what are you trying to do and like and
the bigger the mission you have the more
people fight because it's Chang they
they want to protect the status quo and
so if nobody's hating on what you're
doing then you're not you're not
actually living a great life um in my
opinion you don't have an important
enough Mission and
so expecting people to to hate on on
your ideas uh and then be able to deal
with it I think are some of the key
things that keep coming up over and over
and over and over again across all
successful people the idea with 2%
difference is when we come up with an
idea like I'm going to launch a YouTube
channel I'm going to write my own book I
want to start a Instagram book account
like I want to do whatever we all have
these ideas of what we want to do the
first thing that we typically do is
start planning researching planning
who's done it before who can I model and
learn from all these ideas and we create
this giant list of plans and what we're
trying to do is plan to the 100% which
which is like that's what our final
destination is going to look like how do
I plan to get my goal and then we end up
waking up the next day and you look at
your plan you're like I can't do that I
thought what I'm not that there's no way
I can do that it's not even like us
telling our friends or our spouses or
it's it's us telling ourselves that we
can't do this and so the problem is we
used our energy our our our mojo our our
best like high Vibes on planning instead
of on doing where again the biggest
thing people are missing just momentum
planning doesn't really count as
momentum you have to go and do something
and so instead of worrying about
planning to get to 100% of our goal
completed the 2% difference is just
start with the first 2% what's what's
the first 2% and we don't care about
getting to the end goal we just care
about getting started so that was me in
writing the book okay well I'm going to
write the book after this Instagram live
I'm going to start right now it's easy
for all the thoughts to start to
overwhelm yourself and I did like I
don't have time for this I this is not
on my plan I'm busy I have to I feel
like I'm going to be a bad father a bad
husband a bad uh manager a bad CEO like
I don't have time for this right and I
share all those thoughts in the book too
so you kind of peak behind the window it
wasn't like I really was desperately
wanting to do this going in and then uh
I just started writing so like if
anybody out here you want to write your
first book cool the the 2% difference is
write the first page
and it's okay if it sucks if you want to
start a YouTube channel 2% difference is
record your first video and it's going
to suck awesome cool but more important
than planning how to make a book or
planning how to record a YouTube video
is to just start doing the thing and you
build momentum if you want to start
building a healthy habit you want to you
want to you want to start working out
right this is where we often get
overwhelmed like I want to work out I
want to look good next year I want to I
want to feel comfortable naked or
whatever we want to be able to do cool
so it starts off with this very simple
concept but then the doing becomes
really complicated because as you start
to plan and research a health Journey
right it's like oh well do I do weights
do I do cardio how much of each do I do
uh do I do classes do I hire a coach do
I how much am I supposed to wait am I
going to hurt myself am I going to
injure my back trying to do this thing
maybe I should take maybe I should go do
soccer or pick up a sport or pick up uh
basketball or oh but do I need a partner
to run with like can I overtrain and how
about nutrition like do I need to drink
am I drinking too much water not enough
water do I need to go carnivore or vegan
and all of a it's like so many this is
what happens we get so overwhelmed with
all the potential options which then
leads us to try to plan plan plan plan
plan plan plan some more but then you
can't understand all of the various
options and then we end up getting this
is great I'm not doing I'm I'm out I'm
done and then you stop before you even
started right and so the key is 2%
difference if if you want to start a
health Journey get down on the floor and
do five push-ups or 10 or two right is
it going to make you extra strong no but
it's the first step and most people wait
a decade to take the first step and so
that's what the 2% difference is all
about do you feel like some people are
just that entrepreneurs are
born I know you say that everybody has
enough to serve but you think there's
some people that are just more prone or
um more gifted or more capable when it
comes to
um achieving
entrepreneurship so I think I think
everybody has what I call Michael Jordan
level Talent at something okay uh if you
go religious you know everybody's a
child of God you were created you are
beautiful you should be making something
amazing in the world you are not meant
to be living this small life right so if
everybody has Michael Jordan level
Talent at something for some people
that's being an entrepreneur for others
it might be being a teacher in the
school right it could be many things
how do you find it well you need to
explore you need to taste you need to
test you know just like you found my
videos you were searching for motivation
and you found them and then you he like
I like this and then you dop into it a
lot of times you can't think your way
through these things because chances are
the thing that you should be doing is
very different than what is in your
family and in your circle most of the
time the thing that you should be doing
with your life is very different than
what your parents did or what your
brothers or sisters or cousins or
Community or church people that are
doing and so it takes courage to go off
and do it right if if you're if you're
working with women who have a belief
system of well women are supposed to be
this way but then they know that like I
don't want to be that I'm I'm greater
than that I know I'm greater than that
right yeah to have the courage to chase
that dream down I think is important and
that's where I think people like you are
a voice make today
count uh I try to go into every day
thinking I want to make something today
that my grandkids are going to be proud
of so like this interview with Michael I
want my grandkids to see it I want to
tell my grandkids a story about this
crazy guy Michael who stayed up till
three in the morning to interview me and
now he's off with Grant Cardel is his
business partner running all of these
multi-billion dollar real estate
Investments like I wanna I wanna I want
to make today count and I think it's so
easy to put something off till tomorrow
or the next week like that's a great
idea that I learned from Michael I'll do
that tomorrow and then it becomes the
next day and we we think we have so much
time and then you look back it's like
where did the past five years go like it
just what happened I wanted to do all
these things and nothing has happened
yet and so again if you approached every
day with the mindset of today I'm G to
make something that's going to count I'm
gonna make something that I want my
grandkids to see and again if you take
that approach every day you're gonna
make some amazing things over the next
year what are some of your best tips and
practices for entrepreneurs staying
charged staying focused and growing
really in their leadership and as
entrepreneurs so first off I think you
have to be do something that you
absolutely love if you look at any of
the successful entrepreneurs you look up
to or in any field athletes singers
musicians artists you have to love the
work of what you're doing and not just
try to be YouTube famous if you're
watching this trying to be YouTube
famous it's not going to get you
anywhere you have to love the actual
process of making videos and being able
to influence people yeah editing wise
that you landed that plane love it okay
so what else the important thing really
is that you need to have a morning
routine that sets you up for Success so
we talked about like what's one thing
that you can't miss you need to have
that can't miss stuff in your morning
routine to get you charged to energized
because too often what happens is people
get motivated you watch one of these
videos you're not subscribed yet you
haven't hit the Bell so you only through
one video you get all pumped and then
next day you wake up and like it's gone
yeah and we all we all have that we
don't say we do but we have it you wake
up nobody wakes up every day like Mega
passion to go and so you need need to
whatever that is that gets you excited
if it's if it's watching this guy every
day then watch him every day like you
need to put that into your morning
routine so you start your day feeling
energized and bold and on fire to go do
amazing things as opposed to shrinking
down and then hoping by accident you
come across something that gets you
pumped up I think you need to make big
decisions with your heart and the small
ones with the head so I didn't know if
it'd be worth
it but that's like should I move to
California or should I marry like you
know are you are you seeing somebody I'm
assuming you're not married yet no just
like so you're thinking about like are
you going to marry somebody how do you
know if it's going to work out well you
don't but your heart tells you to do it
so you do
it so it's the same thing like should
you go be a podcaster how do you know if
it's going to work out well you
don't but you want to do it so you go
and do it and it doesn't mean you go all
in and you have to quit everything I
love small testing and you know proving
that the momentum is paying off but you
don't know how everything's going to
work out but if you stayed on the same
path you're on you don't know how that's
going to work out either you know like
if you're going to school and the pathes
you become a dentist versus I'm GNA go
be a podcaster and try to be an
entrepreneur well you don't know how the
dentist path works out either will you
be happy as a dentist probably not we be
Happ happy as a podcaster I don't know
maybe nobody knows but until you go off
and do it and so um big decisions with
the heart if you are feeling like it's
you need to do this then the worst thing
to do is to not do it and then get to
the end of your life and look back and
say man I wish I just started that
podcast I I could have just gone down
the street and bought some microphones
and just started and honestly I was just
too afraid and I never started I think
we want to progress we want to grow we
want to learn we want to improve I think
if there's nothing in your calendar that
scares you that doesn't give you a
little bit of anxiety Then I think you
hate your life it means you're just
doing the same thing over and over and
over and over and over again there's
nothing new you don't like your life if
you're not progressing and learning and
growing um so anytime you
have that idea of something that you
want to do and then your heart's beating
and you're you're nervous I I think
that's go time I think that means you
have to go start it and try to chase it
down and constantly battle the the lack
of belief and the voices in your head to
go do the next thing I I think it's I
think anybody who doesn't have that is
not doing anything big and is not
challenging them themselves to grow
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hasht believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome and if you
want to watch Evan's top 10 rules for
Success check out the video next to me I
think you can enjoy continue to believe
I will see you there there's a lot of
talk in the Creator Community now about
burnout you know people one year in on
their career and they're burning out
it's like well I've been doing this for
14 years and haven't burnt out yet I
still love the process of doing the
thing so what is work